what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos a couple
announcements before we start the show
the first is that we have two clips
channels the first is just pearly clips
and the second is Pearl daily both are
linked in the description the second is
that we have four membership tiers the
first lets you be a part of the live
chat the second you get to be a part of
our discords and our behind the scenes
Vlogs the third you connect with me on
social media the fourth you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month
guys big announcement okay
they took away my Instagram this week
[Laughter]
early things one
um
um also guys thank you for 675 000
subscribers um it's mad that we're
already at 675 000. my goal is to get to
a million before New Year's I don't know
if we'll hit it but that is a very
ambitious goal for the channel so make
sure you guys are subscribing to the
channel
um on top of that guys
um go follow my Tick Tock uh my first
second third and fourth one also got
banned but I have a fifth one so just
probably thinks dot five and just pearly
things six so today we have a lovely
panel so why don't we go around everyone
say your name your age your relationship
your relationship status and a fun fact
about yourself starting here and then go
around okay OG 23 I'm on the single
um I just graduated in a business
management
laughs
[Applause]
yeah
um my name is China the manager I feel
like I've done this like six or seven
okay well then do a new fun fact
anything
fun fact I learned how to make
um
pumpkin pumpkin Fritter I learned how to
make pumpkin shake
um I learned how to make pumpkin uh soup
was that what that was the pumpkin [ __ ]
I was so confused it was pumping and
coconut like it was like a what was in
the pot in the pot yeah yeah yeah it was
pumpkin um soup
yes but I did not made um pumpkin
flatbread like a flat it was good and
what about the pumpkin plantain type
thing no they're so good that was really
good I know we made it all from um did
you say plantain yeah it was a bit it
was made out of pumpkin planting
West Indian right
he did a cooking lesson with Auntie yeah
yeah so I was just gonna ask are you in
wife's school now
well he's in husband's school
yeah I got put into the husband school
and she hasn't even made it yet but she
just told me yeah like China that's
that's Cosmic episode episode one
husband score you went through it yeah
Auntie's Auntie's teaching yeah
apparently I mean husband school
let me know let me know if you're in
London you want to come on husband and
wife school we already started yeah
um go ahead uh I'm South yeah I am based
in London and Dubai I'm in a
relationship and a fun fact about me
um I don't know if this is true or not
but I can I think I can do any accent if
you give me an accent to do I believe I
can do it really really well I go in
German go not German
Scottish not Scottish
okay give me Irish Irish I could do
Oreos really well I think so do you
think or no no I know it's [ __ ]
amazing and I could do Australian really
well like hi guys I'm from Sydney is
that good or no I don't know if I'm good
but in my head I sound good so yeah
there's my fun facts
oh go ahead oh me yeah my name is but my
friends call me King I'm 31 years old
I'm a filmmaker
based in Manchester
you have a fun fact
um fun fact I
I can sow men's African Menswear
um I'll go by big gang I'm 28 I'm taken
uh fun fact is that I've been connecting
bids since 2019. geez
okay so today's topic um we just have
something light you know fun what's
feminism a mistake
so um broad question just generally yes
or no is feminism a mistake here and
then go around
uh
why why because I feel like those
there's a few steps that have gone you
know what I'm saying they've gone
they've gone a good way you know what
I'm saying but certain times you can be
taken a bit far in it so I'll say no for
now okay
um so when you say feminism
so the initial idea of what feminine was
meant to be then yes women have the
right for equality and all that all
those types of things but from what it
was initially to what it is now they're
not really because when it started they
were known as terrorists they planned
assassinations okay well not that far no
but what I mean is like the idea like
the idea of women being able to do
certain things I have no problem with
that but then it's what's been created
from that to this new age feminism and
sometimes people call toxic feminism
whatever you want to call it uh Neo
feminism it's just a bit extreme and
that's and that's the one which we tends
to tend to see modern modern day okay
um for me I think it was a mistake I
lived a quite a feminist lifestyle for
quite some time not actively not
realizing but just being from this
culture and stuff and uh for me
personally I find it a mistake what do
you mean you lived a feminist I'm
independent uh financially and all those
things and I kind of pursued my career
for a really long time I pursued my
academics for a really long time I
really appreciate all of that but um I
think as you get older you realize how
unfulfilling all of those things are and
when you're sold that dream for a really
long time you're so convinced that that
can't wait and you're so convinced that
marriage kids and becoming at all those
things that are more traditional can we
when really biologically it's the other
way around so for me I would say it's
been a mistake I'm curious what age did
you switch your thinking I've always not
realized I it was like this I never
realized it was just part of life it was
just like you go study you go carry on
and you become more career but as I
became more academically astute I
realized that it's actually hindering
some of my more uh nurturing and like my
core values and so I would say that as I
turned about 26 I realized that I'm I've
got all of the things I need in life but
I'm not fulfilled so clearly I've been
sold the wrong dream no so I'd say
around then around 26. okay what do you
think was feminism a mistake
um I'll say no only because I think the
general idea of why feminism was started
it came with good intentions I would
like to believe but I also support the
Dave Chappelle joke where he said the
feminists should have picked a man to
lead their cause in it
I think the problem is obviously
feminism started before social media was
a thing
um and now you've just got too many
people online
stating their opinions that just don't
need to be heard and they're just
radicalized uh sort of a pure movement
and just made it toxic
so out of the people that said yes what
good came out of feminism
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah I'm one of those ones I don't what
do you guys vote does everyone vote
yeah yeah I do whatever in the US no I
don't actually vote to me yeah so I'm
curious if you had to be drafted the
same as a man if that if you had to do
that in order to vote would you do it
absolutely no I don't care like I really
don't care about what's going on I don't
feel so I don't care enough about these
things in life to fight for it because
it doesn't affect my uh reality so the
laws and this that and the other it
doesn't really affect my personal
reality enough for me to want to go get
drafted to both yeah it's not serious
enough no it's interesting because there
is there is a certain I won't name names
yeah I'm a YouTuber that like I was
saying that I because I think feminism
from the beginning has been freedom
without responsibility so they wanted
the freedom to vote without the
responsibility of being in the draft and
a lot of people think that like that it
was something we had to fight for but it
was actually a freedom
um that men had because they had the
responsibility and and it's kind of like
I don't know yeah because we talk a lot
about how women were oppressed because
they couldn't vote but men were like had
to go to war and so it's like you're
that oppressed because you didn't get to
vote but your husband is now being
drafted and potentially killed and come
back with PTSD if he does survive and no
survival no therapy nothing like that so
I don't see how we had it so bad
comparatively I think everybody had it
bad I hope we had it pretty good yeah oh
my God Julian I would have loved that
life so no I don't understand why we
were seen as the oppressed back then I
don't I didn't see as an oppressive I
didn't think it was one so I think men
were really repressed back then going to
war and all this stuff that they didn't
even know anything about and then being
forced to just do it I think that was
more oppressive than not being able to
vote
okay who else said yes
so what are you pretty much yeah okay
okay go ahead what do you what do you
guys think what Freedom did we get out
of them that was good I didn't say it
was good okay for Freedom
um I don't know what it is it's just
more about the option I think that's
that was the main thing is just having
the option to be able to do the same
things doesn't necessarily that you need
to do the same things but just the fact
that it's not a no if you want to I
think that's the main thing okay
do you guys think that women should be
equally drafted now that we can vote Yes
so front lines actually no yeah of
course Frontline front lines yeah equal
rights equal right now why because I
mean if if women are equally drafted
then it's not like your opponents are
going to draft women equally they're
going to come with men so you're just
going to lose at the end of the day no
no we do it they do it it becomes a
whole worldwide thing and women actually
get the equality
no but what I'm trying to say to you is
is if if across the world women want
equality and they want the same rights
as men right so if you want the right to
vote which is fine I'm not saying we
shouldn't but why shouldn't we I'd say
the main reason why that's not the case
is because just like you've seen in the
whole Ukraine situation the women need
to kind of be with the kids yeah not if
we prescribe to what more than women say
no they don't no no but if if there's a
war if the war kicks off you've got men
going to war if the women go to war as
well who's going to look after the kids
I know but we're prescribe them to what
is supposed to happen this isn't what is
being taught now what has been taught
now is they can do that and if they if
that's what they scream at from the from
all the social media and everything then
we should give them the opportunity but
in real life they don't want to do that
no no opportunity is fine that's fine
but obviously in reality you can't like
if you said the right women and men have
to go to war then who's going to look
after the kids no but they don't say
they don't go to war because to so what
you're saying is I agree what you're
saying but the reason that women say
they don't go to war is not because
they're staying at home to look after
the kids so what you're saying is women
women shouldn't be drafted because they
need to stay at home to look after the
kids but then what they would argue is
no we're not staying home to look after
the kids we want equal back to you so
all I agree with you all kicks off from
there is not a single woman that's going
to be saying that yeah all the feminists
will go quiet I'm just trying to solve
the contradiction no I get this yeah
that that was my point and there was
like a clip of me that was taken out of
context where I said if I had to pick
between getting drafted and voted like I
would give that [ __ ] up easy yeah I am I
am scared I will not be on the front
lines I swear to God what you want me to
cook
what do you want me to clean I saw your
picture swear to God I'm running to the
kitchen
and I also think like having so many
options isn't necessarily good for
everybody I think it's like having the
option to do everything you want doesn't
necessarily mean you'll be happier
sometimes it can make you quite confused
and you get distracted and I know I
experienced that in my life so I know
that like feminism gave women all these
options to do whatever they want but I
don't know if that actually leads to
life satisfaction having too many
options you do realize right and I like
the fact that you're saying that because
this is one of the things that we see
when it comes down to things like um
comparison that like
and bodies right though most of the
reason why people unhappy is because
they've they can always compare into
something so if you've never had an
experience people can call it naivety
but when you have too much of an
experience you're always going to
compare something to you so when you say
it like that it's one of those ones
where they've told you you can do all of
these things and sometimes when you
actually do some of these things you're
like yeah because
psychologically even when you go to a
restaurant when there's too many things
on the menu you can actually that's
and that just applies to life so that's
why I don't think having so many options
is necessarily A gift
um in life
feminists who disagree though
who said that as a feminist who disagree
why yeah because that's that's what
their whole movement is
um I feel
well I think and I know that most of the
reason
um that they come out on sale of these
things is because they're just trying to
prove that they can do exactly what a
man can do and the funny thing is when
it comes to men
you hardly find any of us arguing and
trying to prove that we are stronger
than you are doing all of that even
amongst ourselves naturally you know
when you're in a room with guys everyone
just kind of knows where they belong and
then just automatically sort themselves
out but I just noticed that whenever
women are involved in that kind of
equation then things just go out of
place and then again
yeah so yeah I don't know I don't know
how it is have you ever I think Kevin
Samuels used to use the analogy of
um there's some TV show where they put
women and men on an island Fear Factor
no it wasn't it wasn't Fear Factor the
grills yeah and it was like where they
had to survive yeah and the woman like
they had to save within like two days
and the men were completely functioning
they need a bit Wi-Fi there by the
second the second week or something so
why do you guys think there's this
disdain towards men from feminists when
they say they want equality
I've got like they're just conditioned
to do it I feel like they're just told
that men are the enemy but if you speak
to many women and ask them about their
lived experience very few will say oh my
male boss was a nightmare or this man
was so bad they'll always say oh I had
this boss she was a right [ __ ] and it's
always a woman and always and as we all
know like I know from being my
experience on social media with women
and stuff it's always been more most of
my difficulties in life have come from
other women so I always combine like my
lived experience with my thoughts
whereas I think a lot of feminists
haven't even even branched it out to the
idea of what is my life experience been
like have men actually been oppressing
me has it been more women stopping me
from progressing at work and if they
took a moment to actually reflect on
that they realized men aren't the enemy
and it doesn't mean anyone's the enemy
but men definitely aren't the enemy and
I think they're not given that option to
kind of um all given that encouragement
to reflect on their own experiences I
blame social media
because the loudest people online are
the people that have been scorned that
are just upset about stuff for the sake
of it so they're the people that are
just in the comments making all the
noise and then that kind of shifts The
Narrative of what people actually think
is normal when in reality most women
probably don't think like most feminists
it's just a very small percentage of
angry women but they're vocals exactly
so it kind of magnifies it makes him
seem like there's more of them than
there actually are just because they're
the ones that are the most vocal whereas
all the normal women that are just
getting on with their lives that don't
think that way they're just sitting
there watching they're not really
entertaining yeah but bro women need to
call other women out because that's
because it's like there's a very small
proportion of women right I think that
is right and but they're loud and their
voices are Amplified and the women that
actually is not the majority is actually
the minority that's doing that they
don't say anything and women don't like
to be called out so for what do you say
don't want to sit next to you
but basically she said that but when it
goes on social media not in a manuscript
just anywhere else they're gonna call
her pick me a pick me up no exactly but
again but that's the same loud hurt
women that are saying you're a pick me
because you're actually talking sense
but if there's a hundred pygmies they
won't even I think if it is five year
ago I'm with you and maybe like five and
that's how mad it is so but she's not
read more of them just to stand up but
but so I'll get women in my DMs and
they'll be supporting what we're doing
and it'll be like yeah see you on
Pearl's show to come up to me but where
are they in the comments when the girls
are trying to call them call us
misogynists and all these types of
things only for literally speaking in a
way that men haven't spoken before
because men lie so when you get men that
actually you're honest to you that's why
I say women love lies and cheaters
because they don't want men that's
actually telling the truth because when
men do they label them all man as a
thing
um they want cheaters because they
always go for the top 20 of men and the
men that have access to more women they
want polygamy relationships because not
because they will have a baby with a guy
that's already had a baby with another
woman you are sharing a man once you do
that in their mind they may think oh you
know what he's not with her no more but
if you give a man
if you allow my top baby with another
woman then come and have Baby View
afterwards then you're actually allowing
him to have the best of both things you
know what I mean so yeah violent violent
felons have more children than
non-violent yeah and I said this before
like and I thought about it and I know
one of my like you know like it was a
good old friend I don't have to speak
about his name but just he's literally
what she's talking about he would be the
most red flag you could think of but for
some reason better girl
like you know even get a little blue
tick movement imagine like yeah you're
supposed to have some type of nah it's
just I just I think when they say
digmatize I think it's real you know do
you think that the the quality of women
drops when it comes to these types of
guys or do you think it's still top tier
I wish I could say I think you said my
thing is a mentality thing yeah it's
just hardly why I didn't know I wish I
could say it was like dead cat
that's why it even makes you you know
what sometimes I think
it's like if I see your baby father or
not and I had high high levels for you
and then I see your baby father I was
like oh is that all of a sudden it kind
of drops and you've always said that you
kind of you can't get no pretty much
higher than your baby forever so you're
seeing a stunning woman or whatever and
then you see the guy that she's given
the highest honor to and you just you
was feeling a little bit like maybe she
was out of you disappointed and then you
see that you're like
so I mean what what's the stereotype
stereotype stereotypes exist for a
reason right and young women are the
like the most valuable to men right in
in general throughout all of time and
young women date who Bad Boys um so at
the peak of our youth infertility we
tend to waste it on Bad Boys yeah
and but you need the bad boy thing Gene
noticed that women stop going for bad
boys as they get older or do you think
it's still in them I think I think that
women
um just can't either can't get the bad
boys they used to get and so in their
head they settle um
they're like oh I grew out of it but I
just
[Laughter]
they just feel to be honest with
themselves and say that I can't get that
guy anymore yeah or they can't get him
to commit like that's what I see more
it's like they want the bad boy but they
can't lock him down like no one can
right so it's like they can't lock him
down and so then this is it's
interesting to hear from like the men's
point of view because like to women this
is more of like new information but to
men they're like yeah we've been knew
this but do you think that men also like
bad girls do you think nice girls get
finished last as well because I always
hear guys girl lots of talk about how
women like bad guys but I see lots of
nice women being ran through as well
like just ignored or just in the back
burner while he kind of does his thing
with lots of other women it's not hot
enough yeah maybe and I wouldn't even
say that as well nice girls finish last
as well are you a really nice girl if
you're going for the bad boy that wants
the top 20 and this is that thing again
so you can as a nice girl you're a nice
girl but you're making bad decisions
yeah that's true you're still trying
even after the go so the guy that which
all the all the bad girls want as well
so if you're a nice girl you put
yourself in that in that Marketplace
then you just become another one of many
yeah a real nice girl will say you know
what I like him and maybe for one night
but reality for long term no he's not
gonna many girls have to make the
decision they have to pick between yeah
they wouldn't connect and not the girl
and that bad guy between the the short
thing versus the you know what I mean
he's gonna he's gonna get my door kicked
off by the police car and it's like when
you make that decision we actually judge
you differently because yes you could
have carried on looking at the sky's the
limit and that hypergamy thing but you
said no I'm gonna cut off here and this
is the thing which women can't do they
don't know when to actually say you know
what it's time for me to cash out yeah
that probably means a lot of women don't
like actually know when a man's lying so
you get these good girls that will think
that they've found a good guy
he's actually a bad guy in Disguise
that's true and he's just playing that
act and right and a lot of these girls
some some girls are very naive though
some girls are very nice I think okay I
think a lot of girls don't actually
understand me okay okay okay that can
happen to you once you can get
bamboozled once
but what is her body count one this girl
that got bamboozled
I think if women don't have many male
friends and all their friends are girls
they tend to be more naive about what
male Behavior looks like so the ones
that don't have many male friends they
don't really get how men move whereas if
you have a lot of men around you you
learn some of the tricks of the trait so
I do think sometimes they can be more
naive especially if they're asking other
girls
I'll give you one time but it's like
okay he did it he did it he did it he
did he did it and you're still naive
that don't make sense to me yeah like I
just like for me yeah
everyone's allowed one even two like you
know what I mean like we'll give them
tips we'll give them two we'll give them
two the only reason I'm giving you two
is because like they've been telling me
I need to get a little bit better with
trying to like I don't know I don't know
I'm listening to people so I'm gonna
give you two just because people say oh
real life stuff happens and okay so I
want to be a real life person we'll give
you two but how many times do you get to
keep them making the same
um mistake or doing the same offense
getting arrested for it but I think I
think you're underestimating like the
level of gaming some guys have you know
I mean like a lot of guys are like
slippery
if there's ten guys how many have game
would you say out of ten two all right
but if if it's a stereotypical bad boy
okay so let's two so she could have
picked the eight nice guys good guys and
she picks the guy with game and that's
the stereotypical bad boy I just don't
feel bad like
from what I've seen is that the guys
that are smooth talking have got game
that are players they'll have good girls
bad girls bad bees this that any other
but like the good girls fall for the
same lies the but like the babies like
like yeah they all fall for the same
lies and they don't have a clue what's
going on they don't they're genuinely
clueless and they'll be crying to their
friends saying like I can't believe we
did this because they genuinely don't I
no I used to I used to kind of think
like you
no it's not though like it's not even
that I'm switched on it's just like I've
just heard girl after girl after girl
come on my show and like I got cheated
on by him him and him and it's like how
many times were you bamboozled this is
it though it's like yeah but you know
what it is yeah and it's like you must
have liked something about the toxic
relationship because you're still
talking about him three years later so
it's something with you that you're
attracted to him like I just don't buy
it like one of the things that I hate
and one of the things we're suffering
with is all these women with trauma but
like we cannot remove accountability and
you're removing a woman's accountability
unless it was great we have to say that
this woman said yes she laid down she
opened her legs and she let these bad
boys come into her and this is one of
the things that I keep saying is because
if we don't what are we saying oh
manhatt game and because man had bars
yes man had bars man had a game but she
didn't have to fool for it so end of the
day is
if you go and breed out some girl and
she's some badena and she's like you
know she's like she's just a walking red
flag and then you start crying later No
One's Gonna feel sorry for you bro like
that literally because you didn't do
your due diligence yeah so a lot of men
do this they go and have babies with
women that they shouldn't have babies
when they start talking about my baby
mama drama I would have never even gone
there in the first place but you did for
any reason and now you've got problems
the same way with these women if you're
a good girl you know a bad boy all the
things inside your body tell you but
because he's the top 20 he's good
looking he's got whatever he's got you
want him then it goes bad because he's a
child and he does what exactly what Chad
and tyrones do and then you want to
acquire blue murder then you meet us in
your 30s and now you've got a lot of
trouble when you're talking about my
mistrust for guys none of this mistrust
came from me why am I paying for for you
deciding to get run through in your in
your 20s by some guys I hear that and
obviously them kind of women in their
30s that you got to stay clear of the
ones with the Mad trauma because it's
all I've done wrong it's not it's not
all of them there are there are the
thing is it's not 80 that's what we're
dealing with if you make 10 goals eight
of them are suffering from my hair done
I heard that yeah that's probably true
if you but that's what I'm saying but
it's not all it's not all but if you can
maneuver through the history but if it's
80 that's still alive that's
like every girl like me
I mean like honestly I think even
earlier than that I think by 25 most
girls have had their heart broke once
I think about 25. yeah I was giving them
basically what I'm saying is right yeah
okay and another reason why women get
their heart broken early is because
they go for these bad bad boys right and
if you're in your 20s and you haven't
you know the world hasn't hit you hard
yet and a lot of times they'll date the
oh the older guys now there's good guys
all the guys which you can date and
they're not gonna ruin your heart all
these older guys that are gonna show you
about something and then once it all
starts to happen the trauma starts to
happen so all I'm saying to women is
whenever you speak to women men will lie
like initially it was supposed to be
your father your brother that was gonna
vet these men that will come into your
life now with the
women women are having the same
relationship with their brothers there's
no one really spitting this game to them
so when you hear it from a man and
you're in your 20s on your 30s it sounds
like it sounds like we're trying to stop
you from doing certain things we're just
saying no like you should have been told
that I I agree with you to be honest
that the way I see it is that I just
think a lot of women don't actually
understand the men enough you know I
mean they don't actually fully
understand men so that's why they end up
falling into the same track do you guys
think modern women need men
hell yeah everybody everybody yeah to
everybody men need women women need men
it's how human beings are designed we're
designed to complement each other and I
think just I don't think men need women
you don't think so why not because they
would survive without us we wouldn't
survive without them they run the
infrastructure of society they do all
the hard jobs if they if we if we
disappeared tomorrow if outside of
reproduction they would keep living
single men are more likely to commit
suicide single men are more likely to
have mental health problems single men
are more likely to die with depression
um there is biological needs for men and
women they need each other that's how we
designed the majority of men haven't
reproduced historically as in that cabin
had kids and what do you mean but only
only 40 of men have reproduced
historically so I know I said outside of
reproduction yeah so so the whole point
is the info like I understand that men
would prefer to have a partner but the
whole point of society would keep on
going on if women and disappeared
tomorrow wouldn't be the same for
I I think it depends on how you define
whether the survival if it's based on
yet just getting things done absolutely
but if it's based on having emotional
kind of security I don't think anybody
can I don't think he or any human can
literally live a happy life if they
don't have a connection with the
opposite so it was somebody that's a
female point of view like because
because there's a whole group of men
that are walking away from relationships
it's called mgtow and a lot of the like
the ones
the difference but men is men going
their own way they're walking away from
relationships because they just don't
think women bring much to the table
anymore women don't bring much or they
can't get the woman that they want what
percent of women are virgins and 22 and
want to get married and traditional
nowadays they're not all men want but I
think that's great but I don't think all
men need that I mean historically that
that is always what men have wanted yeah
I get that but I don't think now that's
the essential criteria of what you you
want and what you need what you need is
you do need companionship men don't have
an outlet they can't talk to their
friends about things they can't talk to
anybody about their emotions but they
just feel like you can talk to your
friends what's better talking to your
friends or talking to your woman about
your emotions I'm gonna just I'm gonna
just say this and I want to just like
I'm gonna look to the camera and say
guys do not talk to your girlfriend
about your emotions why do guys say this
I feel like that's a lot of a red pill
talk
have to disagree but I think when you
when you find a real one I don't know
then you can talk to about it yeah so
there's there's some things that men are
supposed to be in women's eyes and
there's some things that are never
supposed to see and your woman's not
supposed to see you cry I don't care if
your family passes away you're not
supposed to cry and it's not because
you're not emotional you come acquired
to me come acquired to your boy come and
cry to your sister you're gonna cry to
your woman they sometimes like
women it's not their fault they just
like hypergamous inside their bodies
like they thought when she you know that
thing my mom said get the ick they won't
even understand why they do it but
seeing you crying will just knock down
your face dripping have you seen your
face studies
there's studies that have confirmed this
too but there's a different men lose
respect for men after they see them cry
trust me I I think once you have find a
real one though like a like a proper
ride or die then it don't matter you
won't know she's a writer that you cry
are you willing to risk it
yeah yeah I just I just know that what
she requires for me is not seeing me cry
and Noble woman requires that my mom
doesn't require seeing me her son cry
like it's not it's it doesn't mean men
cannot cry like I'm saying cry to your
friend go and speak to your boy about
I'm not saying to you not to speak I
wouldn't cry with my boys how often do
you cry in front of your girl oh that
means like very rarely how often how
long have you been together coming up to
a year okay so so in a year already
[Music]
and that's what I was saying like even
that in itself I was like not even a
family bereavement just and I want to
say it to to men because women don't
understand why they do a lot of things
no but I think there's a difference
between being vulnerable and being
emotional we hate emotional emotional
just means you're overreacting
emotionally to a situation that you're
now removing logic so if a guy gets
really emotional like I I've been in a
situation where a guy gets so emotional
about maybe something on social media
whatever it is he loses his masculinity
he's overreacting that's a
disproportionate response but
vulnerability is opening up and that
leads to connection the question the
question is at what point so at what
point is crying too much it's just when
it's disproportionate to the situation
because you know what's disproportional
he doesn't we do exactly exactly so no
no but this is a bit and it's based off
of what how we feel about masculinity no
but at what point and that's the thing
like it's confusing to men because every
woman's different based on how she feels
and also it's
at what point is it too much I think
there's objective measures of what would
be too much like if it's a family a
bereavement I think most women would
understand but if it's like
um you know your cat's upset and then
you get a lot of things what if he's
just really stressed out at work yes
disproportionate response to cry over
stress that works that would be
disproportionate and Men this is why I
said do not cry because
crying for it
because crying already work can make you
cry like that you can I'm sure you've
had very stressful days
yeah I mean yeah yeah yeah you lost your
you know I mean like so once you tell me
I can cry you don't get to tell me what
I can cry about like so I come to you
and I'm like it's not something we tell
you it's just your masculine energy will
dictate what makes you cry if you should
figure out yourself it doesn't dictate
to you your level of masculinity will
just dictate doesn't it take to you what
gives you the ick so that's what I'm
trying to say to you yeah I'm a Fool
like
um I can cry because I've lost my
channel and I put lots of work into
building something and as an Empire and
now it's lost and you don't understand
how that makes me feel and it's really
doing something to me and you're like
you're just as YouTube what are you
worrying about it's Instagram but you
don't know what I built so I start
crying over this because I was looking
at it I was looking at the media
accompanying the Empire I was going to
build in the network and you just
looking at me like get over it right if
if she gets to ick over that and and she
understands the context behind it like
this is my life I've built this thing
and there's a lot to me and I'm upset by
it if she gets to ick over that then
she's not the right no but once again
what you're saying is yeah but like that
sounds nice but I just don't think it's
honest it's not it's not like like it
sounds nice but in in general women lose
respect for men when we see them cry and
we can pretend we don't but it's just so
what would I say to someone just cry and
risk it all I already know something she
may she may not why would I want to test
it out I just know men are not supposed
to be crying in front of their girl for
no reason and that might be a reason to
me but the fact there's no reason but
she said to me you can cry but you can
only cry about certain things and I'm
not going to tell you what those certain
things your masculinity needs to let you
know what you're allowed to cry about
just don't cry bro
but the thing is yeah
no it's not easy but nothing is same
with women there's going to be certain
things that we do that's levels to it
there's levels to it and but
vulnerability and emotional is not the
same thing you can still be wrong
I want you to keep your relationships
I'm gonna say cry don't cry out there
like loud but I um the perfect amount
that only each woman knows and guess how
about that context is everything in life
I mean I know everything's black and
white so at the end of the day if it's
something that's a big deal yeah and
you're upset by it and then she's not
there for you then that's the wrong girl
yeah get rid of her move on because once
you find the girl that's really down for
you then none of that's gonna matter you
know I mean because context will prevail
and all of that stuff is really great
for short-term dating and stuff but if
we're talking long-term connections
you're going to bury children together
God forbid you might bury your parents
together you're trying to tell me you
can't cry in those moments this is great
for short-term flings this mentality but
if you want a long-term connection you
might have a still birth you and your
man's just been like no no come we don't
know life happens so we're taking I mean
it's just like as a woman for me I
always want a guy that is calm and
strong even in horrible situations so
like and this isn't pretty but this is
just me being honest one of the reasons
I respect like all of the men that I
respect the most I've barely ever seen
them cry
and
I I just think it's it's a lot of times
as women we mean well and we want to be
there for men but I don't think we can
I think it's short term yeah it makes
sense but I don't know my dad cries when
like I leave the country for a couple of
months or stuff like that and
um maybe because he cries when you leave
the country yeah he cries I think it's
just the Asian I'm from Pakistan so he
like just not seeing me every day kind
of affects him and stuff and like you
know so he'll cry when I if I'm going
back to Dubai he'll cry or whatever it
is and uh but he's he's still a very
masculine man and I just think when it's
proportional and it's in line with your
masculinity it's fine but when it's it's
masculine man and he cries every time
you leave the country yeah he does bless
him I'll be honest with you she said
that Paul I just thought about my dad
I've never seen him cry my whole life I
just I just can't I don't know your dad
personally I'm not trying to offend you
I just can't imagine a masculine man
crying every time his daughter leaves
the country he cries every time like it
gets emotional at the idea of me leaving
the country Pearl I've spoke about my
dad before how high in regard to hold
him he was um Diplomat and he's the
chief um back home and he's been through
so much and I just think he's never
cried like never never do you know you
actually have no idea what it is to be a
chief and to run I mean I'm just
thinking the most masculine archetypes
they don't like they don't cry no I've
seen them stressed out I've seen my dad
stressed out like and I'm coming to her
and I'm like but
ugh
I'm quite no they just there's some
things you just do as well for other
people as well that it's not attractive
but I don't think it should be a rule I
think it should be you let your own
masculinity dictate whether you cry or
not no because masculinity dictates you
not actually crying it's actually
femininity which creates crying because
to build your masculine energy so you
cry less wrong I'm not telling men to
hold it in no but you what I'm doing is
I'm saying to men
don't get tricked out your position yeah
do not go and cry to your misses when
you have friends where natural fact you
could be building more bro code and
building them more Bromance as you want
to call it yeah this strengthens your
Unity if you've never done it with your
boys I suggest you pick your closest boy
and you guys start bonding you do not go
and get your girl who's supposed to look
at you like a Superman the guy that
protects me how are you going to protect
her now when you're crying I'm trying to
and the reason I'm trying to say is
because she doesn't mean to do it it's
not her fault it's just in her body it's
not like say if your dad did want to cry
and get upset would he go to your mum or
would he go to his boys
so if he did God forbid safety was an
incident that made him really get upset
would you rather would would the
connection that your mum and dad have
built is it better for him to go to your
mom or is it better to him go to a
friend even now I couldn't imagine my
mom wanted to see my dad cry like I just
because I know
what do you think would be better for
him
to go to my mom right because I wouldn't
want him to go to other Chiefs and to be
seen as a weak because they would see
him as weak exactly no look at the chief
of all chiefs coming to us and crying so
what does that tell you about long-term
connections what are they built on no
but what I'm trying to say trust there's
a trust element with your vulnerability
at this point it would have him looking
weak to the other to the other tribes
right so you don't want to be it's more
important okay it's more important to be
seen masculine outside of the home and
to the world than it is supposed to seem
masculine to your words changing that's
what I'm saying it's changing I feel
like that's generational no but like
okay I'll be honest with you even now
yeah you don't want to be the the guy
that's crying to the girl and and doing
the r b love singing bro because the guy
which ain't do the guy that's doing the
drilling them he's blowing backs out bro
and this is the thing I don't want I
don't want you to be crying in the rain
like like Ray J bro
I'm a CEO and you're you're a boss you
come to your boss and you start crying
to your boss because you're so stressed
out because you're like I can't cry to
my wife wouldn't your boss be like take
that to your home don't bring your tears
in my office
yeah 50-year marriage you're probably
going to cry at some point but the point
is
it as women it's it's dishonest to tell
men to make that a habit occasions
occasionally occasionally occasionally
every couple but every woman doesn't
know what her point is so you don't know
at what point exactly you're going to be
turned off by it and I don't know
exactly what point I'll be turned out so
so it's easier just to tell men you know
what avoid that with your girl do that
with your boys if you can because it's
confusing to men because some girls they
see you cry like there's girls that have
said I saw him cry once and I couldn't
look at him the same ever again happened
one time
there's some girls multiple times that
it'll take why was he crying I I don't
know yeah so PO let me tell you
something I'm gonna you know I'm gonna
we're gonna open up a little bit here I
don't do too much I I know I'm getting a
little bit better with some stuff so
tell him some stuff so
uh my first true love I would say oh
must have been together about five years
uh
um I was I can tell the story you've
seen it but I was I was stabbed when I
was younger very very badly I was on
Live support machine
um people seen the pictures and stuff I
was hooked up the machines and stuff
the girl that said she would never leave
me ever when I was hooked up and I
couldn't walk when I cried and when I
when I had the the cafeteria inside of
me the [ __ ] bag all of that stuff yeah
something happened after that I'm
telling you something like something got
changed the Superman that I wasn't even
though I survived and even though I was
whatever she's happy now she's married
she got her kids in the rest of it and
I'm happy for them were cool but trust
me on this man you could I was on my
deathbed I was hooked up to machines and
the girl that was hooked up the girl
that was standing next to me holding my
hand that said she'll never leave me
stool left me men you have to understand
this are you sure it's due to that or do
you think it could be other barriers it
could be other variables but what I will
say is that
afterwards I found out she wanted to
leave me but obviously this stuff that
happened created Created something in it
and I just know that there's some parts
of being a man that after you step after
his past vulnerability now it's like yo
dependent your dependency kicked the
hell out yeah and she said to herself I
can't do this right and
when you feel that like you're not
supposed to kick out because of because
I'm I need you now you know I mean like
I'm I'm effed up bro I can't even you
know what I mean is that is more her
because because I feel like what you're
doing right now is what people do on
social media too much and that's
generalization that you're based in your
experiences like a girl nobody nobody
said no but essentially you're taking
your experience of your ex and insane
you're saying it's the same thing like
okay not we know not all we we know that
we don't have to say with every
everything it's not every single person
but in general women don't like to see
men cry yeah like like women like
masculine men the most sought after guys
are like tough they're not I'm not
trying to say that this is for like ah
like I'm you know what I opened up when
I get told that
I don't want to be rude but he was
arguing to me like a girl bro I opened
up a story to show you an example I
could give you other examples and other
people you're not trying to say to you I
could literally give you examples let me
give you another one women don't care
about what you go through bro like you
might think they do that's why she was
talking about work
um she was gauging in what it's okay to
cry about at work like you can lose it
all tomorrow in it yeah go and start
crying to girls about you lost it all
and you're not the man you ain't got the
car you had now you've you're not an
apartment no more you've gone to one
room and you will discover how many
girls all of a sudden don't want to hear
stories again
they don't care bro I don't know what
that's fact I'll give you an example
guys and girls crying on the street
yes what is the Public's reaction
they stop for the women they don't for
the men you know what it is for me yeah
I like the thing that just grinds my
gear here is that same thing with the
feminist type thing like I just hate
when people generalize in that's that's
just it so it doesn't matter the
scenario or what you're saying it says I
don't like generalization in general
however you get like a load of women
online just talking [ __ ] about men
because they're generalizing their share
experience with one man and then saying
oh all men are trash that [ __ ] pisses me
off as well how is it a general how do
we have a conversation about anything
about General truths about Society if we
can't speak in generalities
and so if there are if there are studies
that say in general women lose respect
for men when they see them cry okay so
there's studies that back this up
we can't we can't talk about that I I
hear it I hear it but like I said it's
context and everything you know what I
mean so douche you you want every time
we talk about anything to say but not
all
like I'm just asking because I get this
a lot
because I think whenever so if we don't
ever deal in how do we ever come to
um to a general consensus if we don't
deal in yeah that's what I'm saying like
how would we have a conversation about
relationships in general if we don't
talk about in general we'll have to talk
about it it's hard to no but the thing
is everything in life is General it's
not so I think whenever we speak we know
it's not all so sometimes people have to
say stuff like they'll be like um it's
not all yes we know it's not all women
but I think we've come to a general
consensus when we're speaking we're
speaking so we have to say modern women
right they have to say some women it
becomes this thing where I think we have
a level of intelligence that when we all
know we're not speaking about everybody
like we shouldn't keep having to do this
and when we do it with a man this is
something I do with women because they
want to keep moving the goal posts we
should just know that it's not all men
it's not all women if we have to keep
doing that it's because the the
conversation is getting derailed we
cannot ever come to a general consensus
or anything in life unless we do not use
an average yeah and we need to get an
average or we need to get a percentage
or something so and and the example you
used with men are trash and if there was
data that said 80 percent of men were
committing crimes against women okay but
when it's five two percent you know it's
not the same exactly but women
generalize and say all men
the the difference is that in general
most women lose respect for men when
they cry in general most men aren't
trash
once once false one's true
sure enough
um Okay so
let's talk about Andrew Tate
hey sweet top G
um what do you guys think of Andrew Tate
I don't mind Andrew Tay I just don't
really like his followers I really don't
have a problem with Andrew Tate I think
if you are a successful man who does
well and you understand the Dynamics of
men and women he's become Muslim now as
well which is I'm Muslim so anyone that
becomes a Muslim I'm like go and then um
so yeah so um you know any I don't have
a problem with him he's obviously
speaking from his own lived experience
and this is how he gets women to behave
around him but he is a successful man he
works out he's got money he's got all of
these things so he can talk with his
chairs what I don't like is that nobody
kind of guy that follows him and then
starts adopting all his values and
starting having this really angry
attitude towards women and be like and
that's what it almost you think he's
angry not him but I think his followers
aren't what's Angie takes values to you
uh what do you mean by that like because
you said they adopt his values okay your
values as in like oh women aren't like
this is how you should treat women This
Is How They this is what women like this
is how do you get them to submit this is
what you do but you can you can get that
level of submission when you're that
level of guy but if she's not submitting
to you you're either aiming too high or
you're not successful enough as a man
yeah but then he says get more
successful
do you think it's okay for him to say yo
get make a [ __ ] ton of money so you can
[ __ ] a lot of hoes yeah no but I think
that the fact that the guys are taking
on what he's saying about women but not
taking on what he's saying about
business and earning potential and
working out and paying for women are all
these things a lot of them do do you
think so the ones I see in these
comments are the new I I just don't I
see it as like just people if you did
have a lifestyle like Andrew Tate you
wouldn't be so angry against women a man
that's angry against women can't get
women to submit to them and that's what
fuels their anger so I feel like I don't
think they're angry I think they just
have standards like I just I mean we're
talking in general right I just like I
just think they say things like like
they don't want to grow with a low body
count they don't want a girl that's fat
they don't want to but they've got it
like that don't need to say it like that
yeah so you know what the men that have
it the men that I know that have these
standards never need to vocalize it and
never need to watch a podcast on it it's
interesting I I would agree with you
yeah I've met good looking guys that
make good money that have left the us to
go to a different country and they just
say it's better yeah they say I'll get
two matches in the U.S and then I'll get
130 in Poland right
yeah I guess the culture of the women
makes it really difficult to submit but
I genuinely think when you are a man of
value you don't need to follow any man
telling you what to do and also you
don't have an angry attitude towards
women women just like when you're a
woman of value when you're a woman who
gets men uh treating her well you don't
be you're not screaming men are trash
you're not angry against men you don't
have those attitudes because to you men
have always been good similarly if you
find men with high value they don't
experience these type of women who are
running games on them cheating on them
talking out the side of their mouths to
them they don't experience
is the number one reason we can agree
NBA players get [ __ ] right the number
one reason they go broke is getting the
wrong [ __ ] yeah because they choose
badly but if you're a real amount of
high standards you don't choose badly
yeah the vetting process Jeff Bezos yeah
because he picked the wrong number but
just like he was saying nice girls don't
get with bad boys men of value can spot
a thought from a mile off and it's that
simple you can spot a thought that's one
of your skills as a masculine man Alpha
men don't tolerate promiscuity I think I
think they don't have promiscuous women
in their lives the new thoughts
okay okay
what is a thought a promiscuous
I've got a very different standard
because of my culture and my religion so
I can't really speak on other people I
really can't
um so but what I would say is one of the
definitions of an alpha man is you don't
tolerate promiscuity and you vet women
before they come into your world you
don't let any old riff raff in your
house and if you do then you're not
you're not high value just because
you've got money and you've got status
that in itself is not enough you've got
to have levels to it and the levels to
it is you don't let any Riff Raff I I
agree with you on the point that you
know I do think men should vet women
yeah and I do think men should have high
standards yeah
um where I disagree with you is I I
think it's silly to say that you a girl
can't trick a guy I think even if he's
Alpha even if he's high value even if he
has this this and this like I think can
you trick a good woman
yeah
I I no I agree no you can't so what I
would say is if you have especially with
these NBA players most of their women
have like their bodies out on Instagram
and then this that and the other and
this and then they you know and then if
you can't spot from that then you are
not high value what about what about
like what about like Tom Brady's wife uh
Giselle do you think do you think she
was a walking red flag I just think um
Victoria's Secret it depends what you I
think is again that my values are a
little bit skewed because I'm Muslim but
the thing is if your woman sells her
body and that's her primary source of
income she's going to have more liberal
values and when you bring a woman with
liberal values into your home you have
to expect liberal outcomes that's all so
even Tom Brady you're dating a
Victoria's Secret model who makes a
money out of her body and there's
nothing wrong with that but you've got
to recognize with that comes different
types of values and so yeah do you think
then he's not Alpha yeah
so you think Tom Brady is not high value
any man who allows promiscuity and that
kind of had to mother his children I
don't believe his Alpha because Alpha
men are so protective they're so
possessive they don't even risk the idea
of kokodri the idea of their woman
having potential this is if we're
talking evolutionary psychology sense
the alpha man in the pack is my woman
can never go with another man because
I'm not wasting my money or my resources
on somebody else's kid now if you take
that risk in any way shape or form you
lose some of your Alpha you've got to
remember babies happen
but I mean like you could it could just
be like one of your side things a girl
that you're bringing and baby happens
I actually think that um your your
minimizing the fact that we live in a
different Society so women in the
western Society have a different mindset
than women elsewhere so what you're
saying would work in so many other
places in the world but it wouldn't work
in the west yeah maybe because I'm from
Pakistan in my culture if you even have
one body count you're right off you're
just a write-off and it's that and any
man that does go with you he's then seen
in a lower way so maybe my mentality is
obviously skewed from that but I can
still think it applies even when you're
I mean a guy can get a perfect girl like
she could be a virgin and she could
still turn like she could still wish she
could still turn 28. she could still
turn 28 29 and say oh you know at the LA
the last 10 years I've been missing out
and leave him but chances are less but
you're you're right the chances are from
this you're you're right the chances are
less but then does that make that guy
not Alpha that doesn't make sense the
thing is he did his say if he took a 21
year old who then decided at 28 to
become you know whatever she wants he
did his betting by choosing selected
when he chose her he chose right but if
you're choosing a girl at 22 who's been
you know doing the most and then wanting
her to become a wife you lose your Alpha
because part of your Alpha is full sight
you can spot what's gonna be the good
mother of your child if you don't have
that full set you lose your Alpha yeah I
just I just think you're you're
minimizing men's experiences by by
making it that gen like that broad how
come when it came to the women because
because women are because women are born
with value men must create it yeah and
so like a woman loses her value when she
dates a bad boy right but a man doesn't
lose his Alpha just because he picked
the wrong girl I think but for me if I'm
dating a guy and I see that his ex was
you know maybe had a really promiscuous
past I can't [ __ ] with him
because you've got standards that aren't
my level because you'll go for anyone
then and I lose but I think in Brady's
case like yeah there's a lot of girls
that for me that won't date Drake now
because I wouldn't date a guy that's
been like you know I've been with a
certain girl because I'm just like
that's your level because that's your
level you wouldn't date Drake
uh I don't know if Jake would rate me
and that was all I needed to know that
was all I needed to know no no no no
no
but it's not you know what it's okay
because you like the thing about our
series no okay honestly I don't think
any woman it depends what kind of woman
she is but personally if you're a woman
that's looking for a long-term
relationship there's no point dating
Drake so so no but that's not you're
saying I wouldn't date him you're saying
I wouldn't date him because he's not
looking for something serious because it
makes no sense too
long long
terms
that's what I'm saying you're not saying
I wouldn't date him you're saying I
wouldn't date him because he wouldn't
take me long term I wouldn't do anyone
where I can't see the that person
settling down and creating a life with
me why would I date you but the reason
why Drake is probably a bad boy is
because he's gonna tell you that he's
going to be there for the long term and
you're going to believe it but even
Drake's baby mama was a porn star and
stuff to me that makes him lose value no
but you still would date him so he
didn't lose too much value no and that's
the thing like like yeah but this is why
like like I'm just this is what I I used
to think a lot like you yeah but this is
why like a lot of times men will say
don't take dating advice from women
because we don't even know what we want
but you do you think a man who's got a
past of women that are all like
promiscuous or whatever it is if you go
out and eat there a certain way all of
his exes does that not put you off him a
bit no but you moved the goal post who's
talking about one relationship and why
you're talking about anyone that's got a
past on making bad choices is a bad
choice man or woman right so if a man or
if all these exes
are strippers or yeah you know I mean
you know if they'll cheat on yeah
escorts then you're just kind of looking
at the type of guy if all if all the
guys say Tom Brady isn't yeah
you know why she left him she left him
because he said he wanted to go back and
get another ring that's why she left him
and she wanted him to to retire and now
to be at home but you have to understand
you've gone your job as a woman is
you're picked
exercise and you've picked one of the
top like percents of athletes like that
you're not going to get another Tom
Brady's like having a LeBron James and
then he said you know what I'm not ready
to go yeah I still got some more fight
in me so you said you know what I wanted
to retire so I want to now divorce you
that's a selfish thing because your job
as a wife is supposed to support him he
his career isn't finished you might have
thought it was finished but he didn't
finish he's still got more to give so
you divorce him because you say that you
know what this is not what we agreed and
I want to be able to start to live my
life that's a selfish you know what as
soon as she dated Leonardo DiCaprio
should have known anyway man
yeah what do you think about men who
take pictures of their women that are
making only fans and they're the ones
filming it for her to post
okay I'm not saying it's irrelevant I'm
asking what you think about does it
reduce his masculinity
right having a promiscuous woman does
what produces your mask so have you wait
you've equated to just picking a woman
that you might break up with to having a
dune only fans and taking pictures of a
booty generally having uh Association
the point is you keep moving I'm
confused but also I don't I don't think
it reduces his masculinity because I
think a man who posts his who posts
pictures of his woman online is a pimp
masculine
that's where he is I don't think you'd
marry a woman that would be posting or
having an only fans and stuff and if he
did it's still to me it would reduce
your masculinity part of masculinity
isn't just money and appearance it's
also protectiveness of your women that's
an interesting that the um
I'll explain to you why because the
truth is really and truly the most
successful pimps are a different
archetype of man so most times a pimp
has full control over that woman so
that's a masculine trait in in some ways
which is now labeled toxic masculinity
right yeah but that's like the extreme
of masculinity well like you're looking
at it from like men can lose their Alpha
absolutely because that's that's at a
different like
like women are you're looking at it from
a woman's point of view because women
have value and they lose it if if a man
is in the top two percent of men one
percent of men I I don't think he can
lose them lose his I don't think Drake
wait let me finish I don't think Drake
loses his Alpha because he's [ __ ] a
lot of hoes and I think you might you
may be in your culture you personally
but I don't think most girls are gonna
have any issue dating Drake because he
had a baby with a corn star no but with
evolutionary psychology which is defines
the whole of the time part of
masculinity is providing and protecting
protecting means protecting her from
other men that's what protecting means
in masculine terms and when you have a
promiscuous woman that means you either
she's promiscuous before or after you
whatever it is that protection element
isn't there enough and that's what I
mean by that because if you cannot be a
masculine man with that that protective
quality you can't a man that doesn't
protect women is not masculine now part
of that protection is making sure no
other man can access that woman because
that's my womb that's my baby that's my
oven now if you don't have if you don't
exercise with that mentality you lose
your masculinity it's how human nature
is defined I think your view is kind of
scared due to your like culture I'll
just I was thinking we live in a UK
issue
let's talk biologically let's let's take
my religion out of it we're talking
about men living in
prehistoric evolutionary let's take even
before this protecting all the hosts
yeah let's take even let's say for
example we live in a jungle society and
you need to make sure that you're
getting resources for your kids and only
your kids if you've got a woman that's
doing the most you could be feeding kids
that aren't yours so you won't survive
your survival is reduced yeah but
they're biologically predispositioned to
spread their seed to everybody not to
look after everybody else's kid they
don't want to look after any kids yeah
yeah so that's why you don't choose a
promiscuous I don't think they should
choose a promiscuous woman what I'm
arguing with you is you say because
someone chooses the wrong woman they're
not Alpha yeah absolutely
absolutely you lose like but again like
again babies happen right so it doesn't
mean you you lose your your Alpha Mill
that's that status because you've
breeded up the wrong girl if you mean
look Paul if you have if a girl if a
woman has the baby by the wrong guy
she's a feminine woman she's still a
feminine woman so if it doesn't look if
you don't lose your Alpha why do men
feel away if their woman is on only fans
or is on Instagram okay okay if it
doesn't affect you okay all right all
right just wrong I compare only fans to
prostitution right right New Age
prostitution so if you do only find your
prostitute to me I don't I don't mince
my words if you sell your feet picks to
me that's prostitution
um and the men that own only fans are
the biggest pimps in the world and they
they've got women thinking that they're
actually in control of something do you
realize how like and this is not it's
insane no this is actually the the
mental behind it Paul yeah because
they canceled only fans and women got
mad they actually went on the whole
thing and spoke about oh yeah you know
um this is not equality and and you know
I mean women have the rights and you you
campaign for the right to sell you
pictures it's such a
the concept behind it right whenever you
look in the name is something that women
have built yeah in the world right yeah
which doesn't base it's not based upon
sex or sexuality
what business has been built
what do you mean what business isn't to
name me a business a company
that a woman is built in the world
that's contributed to society that was
not met based about sex and beauty
beautification or sexuality
women don't have much Enterprises no no
no no no no no no yeah beyond that no no
women have lots of richest women on the
planet got it through divorce there you
go but the reason you can't think about
it because everything that woman makes
is based upon sexuality and selling it
towards men women haven't built anything
you know what I'm trying to say to you
like so yeah I'll just I was only
thinking about it because I was just
like well I was just thinking when I
think of alpha I think of the guys that
women want to bang that's that's what I
think
I'm thinking like do women still want to
bang the guy with a bunch of kids from
all these different hoes yeah yeah
you're limiting it to dating the real
world in the real world in dating yeah
of course you can still bang a guy who's
bringing lots of hoes you can bang a
future but what like I said giving a man
the highest honor you can which is a
child yeah they still sign up but what
are the levels of the women that sign up
to a man like future Ciara was supposed
to be a colleague
Sierra but she left she left yeah she
left ASAP and replaced it with what kind
of man no but two women don't stick
around no but Shadow babe when she when
she had a baby with future he had how
many baby mums already so this is what
I'm trying to say she didn't care the
fact and that's an amazing strategy
yeah that's that's how it like wait yeah
wait okay that's because it was a mating
strategy it's like she got the the kid
with the alpha and then got the beta to
take care of her later that's what she
did uh but I would honestly just say
that it's um great for dating to have
this mentality we're in a post-marriage
society yeah marriage doesn't make sense
for men today I understand that but the
reality is is that you're defining
success and value on how many people
want to have sex with you and really
it's how many people want to invest with
you if you're a woman and how many women
submit to you if you're a man and their
two value is not defined by how many
people want to have sex with you because
a prostitute can have meat people having
sex and I could put on uh three four
stars I'm still fine and men if they're
just funny but the value is defined by
men a valuable man is by how many women
of value will submit to him and women
what is a valuable woman uh for women
the value is defined by how many men
invest in him and a valuable woman
number one quality a valuable woman is
loyalty because if she's not loyal to
you you're investing in a woman that is
actually belongs to everybody so any man
who can have sex with millions of women
but chooses promiscuous women all the
time he loses his value your value comes
from the women
you tell me guys stop it you're telling
me gangas you're telling me Genghis Khan
yeah was not valuable because he was
[ __ ] everybody no but the women are
they promiscuous he was no they were
loyal to him
everybody I'm not debating his ability
to screw but he's willingness from the
Met let's talk to the man because men
really pick who's high value it's not
the woman what what what makes a guy
high value to you
high value man
so I think high value money is just
someone that can
protect provide
makes makes his money makes his way in
life
to be honest like I'll look at myself as
a high value man right six foot plus bid
got a great job business comfortable in
life everything's going well you know
what I mean so I can really pick
whichever I go I want and at the end of
the day like I'll choose which what girl
makes sense so like the thoughts the bad
bees there for the streets they're for
everyone else you know I mean like I
wouldn't personally pick a girl like
that I'd pick the girl that shows
housewife material qualities I mean so I
think it kind of balances itself out
like high value men will meet their
match eventually they'll run through all
the bad bees and the the crazy thing is
here is that you get all these girls
right there are babies and they'll be
like sixes five sixes sevens at best but
they'll enhance themselves to make
themselves seem like eight or nine right
but then they base their value of the
guys that [ __ ] them yeah right so do you
think it's common for high value men to
sleep with hoes yeah yeah yeah because
because it's easy because it's easy
right it's at the end of the day like as
a high value man you have to pick of the
bunch you can pick the Good Girls the
bad bad bees whoever you want you think
men lose respect for other men if they
sleep with a lot of hoes
okay you're getting more respect because
you know I think who it is like the
thing is it's not easy to actually
sleep with a lot of girls yeah it's not
it's actually very difficult to go out
there and do it you know I mean so do
you have more respect from a man that
sleeps with a bunch of dirty hoes or
just high quality women it doesn't
matter because it's still difficult
regardless like it doesn't matter like
you could be the best looking guy most
successful you go to a nightclub you're
not guaranteed to be no so I mean like
you see a lot of guys at the end of the
nightclubs trying to chase stragglers
yeah right it's not guaranteed it you're
trying to tell the man what's high value
to women but we don't pick what's high
value men pick what's high value yeah
because the men the men have to pick who
is the most Alpha in the room they pick
who leads Society but um part of being a
high value more a man has to involve
what woman you have by your side it's
impossible to say you're a high value
man okay when you have alone I I I I
agree with you on that point so like I
would say if I saw a high value mat like
I wouldn't look at a guy that's married
to her only friends thing yeah and so
you're a high value man because you're a
waste man like why is your girl and only
for
okay I have a question is Drake is Drake
not high value because he had a kid with
an online I thought he was an idiot for
me getting there getting a a Coinstar
preggers right but again like babies
happen like I said babies just happened
he wasn't probably he definitely wasn't
planning that it just happened like so
you can't really lose respect for him in
that sense because babies happen but all
I'm saying is if Drake decided to marry
a porn star then I might look at him a
bit like funny you know what I'm saying
if we go like Beyonce or Rihanna like
high value women let's say for example
do you think that if Drake had a baby
with someone like Rihanna or someone
like you think someone's a high value
woman I would say yeah yeah I would say
so we'll Beyonce I would say so give me
an example she's a 32 year old baby mama
yeah but why would she how is she her
value but who would you classify as a
pie value woman
22 year old virgin and so who would that
be there's one on the show a couple
months ago let's take a 22 year old
virgin do you think if Drake had a baby
the 22 year old virgin or the corn star
what do you think makes him more
valuable the 22 year old exactly
women does have a role no no I'm saying
but but I'll be honest with you Drake
can't lose his value this is like like
yeah
you just can't lose his value you can't
lose his value to low value no no no he
just can't lose his value in order for
Drake to lose his value he needs to
basically do what Kanye done with a 22
year old virgin want to be married to
Drake do you think yes
I think a high value woman has to be
chosen by a high value man I don't think
you can just be a high value Woman by
yourself I think women say that because
they're delusional I could have thought
be a high value for her like a drink
yes she's now high value if she's chosen
by a high value man just high value
status yeah but cornstar has a high
value to you guys well are you joking
have you not seen our cleaned them up go
look at go look at her defining value by
such no no no empty it's not to me
basically to me to me she's the same
right yeah but the society he's gonna
clean her up he's presenting he's now
he's put her back to the Instagram World
actually so Marvel she doesn't she's now
high value no no no no no no no to the
world she's represented her now and now
she's on Instagram and she's doing art
things she's got she's a good little
mummy she really you know that's that's
a superpower that high value men house
yeah he's literally granted what he's
done to her now she's like she works in
Galleries and she does art and she does
these things you know what it is money
and Status change everything in both
sides like so as for a man if you've got
higher value High status and you've got
money then all the rules don't apply to
you and it's the same with women like
you see like The City girls all these
women online they're the ones that are
promoting the most ratchet Behavior yeah
but they will still probably settle down
and marry someone but the difference is
is that them women have money and Status
so they can kind of get away with it to
an extent whereas the women that want to
be like them they don't have the same
money or status so they can't act the
same I just don't think it's true that
nice girls don't go for guys just
because they picked a bad girl at one
point
I don't I don't think Drake is gonna
have any problems do you think that when
a drake say for example a drake takes a
a porn a porn star story
um does he raise a corn star status or
does she decrease his status because to
me she decreases his status he doesn't
raise hers because nothing can raise us
no he's raised hers what
oh wait listen because she could she
could then settle down with her
afterwards she can she cannot because
her ex is Drake and she's got I agree
that a bad woman can lower it guys
absolutely I agree with you I I think
that a bad woman can lower a guy's
status but I don't think it makes him
not Alpha but that's my whole point like
my whole point my whole point my ability
to have sex
the point is that women want to screw
him and why do they want to screw him
because he has money status power
whatever it is defining Alpha by ability
to have sex a dildo can have sex
but the point is exactly people that
have sex doesn't mean Power Respect the
ability to Alpha is not defined by the
ability to have sex it's the ability to
have women submit okay
okay cool I hear I hear I hear where
you're going with it yeah yeah I hear it
but in reality it's not going to be that
way I hear it I hear everything that
you're saying and to be classed as Alpha
you know you can't have to protect
promiscuous women but it will not
diminish straight status and it will not
diminish any man of his status someone
like me might look at that and say oh
that's a l i wouldn't do that but who
the hell am I and what the hell do I
matter even someone of this even another
rappers you saw um what's his name Pusha
T Pusha T literally
finished Drake here but it didn't do
nothing to drink success Pusha T
literally finished straight embarrassed
him about the story of added on let
everyone know about the kid about his
Adidas still mess up the Adidas roll out
but what did it do to Drake in the end
all Drake did was present clean up the
woman bring out his kid and started
doing Daddy in actual fact we oh
everything don't clean up women
you can't clean up women but the thing
is you're also forgetting the fact that
we're in a different Society so yeah in
this particular Western Society
yeah I think America is the worst place
because I don't think America is a real
place
that's been cleaned up I don't think
there's a single woman who's past hasn't
defined her future
she's still not cleaned up she's still
she still knows the streets no way come
on Kim Kardashian is not somebody okay
okay
and yet her sex tape still gets talked
about and she's got little kids that
will see it
okay okay
but the point are you married no I'm not
married okay so the point is her results
are still better than me and you yeah
she got she got three high-value
proposals three not one not two three
but you're so so so we could say we
could [ __ ] under all we want yeah but
her results are better than ours that's
because you're defining results by right
if the men if the men can pick you the
high value men it has to be the level of
men and also your parenting to find out
now if your children can see you naked
having sex with another man you can
never be a high value woman
again
Kim gets a bladder again because money
and status but the reality is if your
children can watch you have sex you are
not a valuable woman I I agree you
should not pick a girl that that has a
sex tape on the internet I'm with you
I'm with you I'm the with I'm with you
and I don't think I'm with you but but
if you're a high value a high value
woman is picked by a high value man and
she was picked more than once so again
news how do we Define a high value man I
don't know what you know actually
actually I'm gonna send Blessing the
clip let's hold on hold on let's you
don't think he's insane
yeah he's a billionaire so so like I
think you can't clean up I stand by that
you can't clean up anything
because look at the tree look at this
like let's take Kim for example if you
try and clean up a woman especially in
this day and age your kids can still see
that mother doing the most you can't
please I agree I agree it lowers your
status as a guy like you can have a girl
that embarrasses you but I just I just
don't think he's not out like Drake is
not Alpha because he screwed a porn star
his child can watch his mom the mother I
think so I think that you're wise a
disservice
Drake did not Marry That Woman again
babies babies but he's still Alpha so
it's like it's right protection the
protection quality of an alpha has gone
out the window he's still out for like
it doesn't have you protected your child
from seeing them
with the woman of his child does that
make ELO must not an alpha damn man this
guy literally runs the whoop like you
know I mean the defining Alpha by just
money or not but we're not but you can't
see the thing about us men we can see us
men can pick the alphas right because
when we're in a room we can literally
put ourselves into um into an older
pecking order we don't need women to do
that you women argue about stuff us men
we can literally go in a room and we can
work it I would argue wait hold on hold
on hold on a second yeah we can work it
out that's why women always argue men we
already know that's what when it comes
down to an argument Movement we won't
argue for more than 60 Seconds because
after 60 seconds we're about to go into
blows because men we don't like to do
those type of stuff we're going to say
what you saying what you're saying and
then we discover who really is that yeah
and then that's the point the point is
like we don't get to pick the men pick
but you uh I think I even had Kevin
Samuel talk about this one so if you
actually we're gonna we're gonna pull up
like Kevin Samuels because yeah Kevin
Samuel said you know your woman does
Define you though yeah I mean he would
say that a woman defines you because he
was talking once about how he went to
some event with uh
it's the woman you choose isn't it
absolutely you're talking about babies
and babies no I just think your choice
definitely removes your Alpha if you
choose promiscuous Elon Musk not a high
value man that's why I said
can we just clarify how we're defining
because for me the protection is as much
as a provision you guys are just
focusing on provision for me protection
and provision is the same thing when it
comes to masculinity it has to be the
same level if you can't protect your
children and your wife you're not high
value no matter how much money you got
and if your children can access pictures
of their mum having sex with other men
you haven't protected that child if the
if your wife can go have sex with other
men or put her body up father when
you're not protecting your woman so the
protection is as valuable as a provision
yes yeah but you I will look at you
different but I wouldn't it wouldn't
change the fact if you're successful
I'll look up Success is Not can I say
something though okay it's all the key
so okay so when we're talking about high
value men we're talking about men that
will earn over six figures have done it
consistently for over five years we're
talking about
um blessing you want to play it are you
gonna you're gonna yeah just um from
this front
because I think we're talking about
Alpha and we're talking about high value
men and I think those are different yeah
I think it's getting a Confluence I
think it's getting it well I would
imagine it's relatively similar Alpha
before he has a woman yeah and that's a
fact
well you could be high value imagine
this we get into a fight and because
because you um you're not in you know
you're not with your baby mum no more
you knock me out man is saying he's not
Alpha I'm with my missing so I'm Alpha
but I just got knocked out by a man that
man that's not with his girl he's
definitely Alpha
yeah yeah God
uh
glad you asked let's define it
one of the best version of themselves
each and every day but who are we
kidding the reason you're here right now
is because the term high value man seems
to be everywhere full disclosure I
didn't create the term guys high value
man has been with us for a long time I
have just put my own unique spin on it
and kind of popularize it and it has
kind of gone viral but here's the thing
so many people are talking about high
value this high value debt and many
times they're actually talking about me
and saying as though well Kevin said
this or Kevin said that and many people
are getting it 100 wrong so in an
attempt to make sense of all this I want
to give you guys the simple six basic
principles that I Define as being high
value now again you don't have to agree
with what I'm saying but this is what
I'm talking about when I'm saying a high
value man so your mileage may vary your
opinion is your opinion but when I'm
talking about it this is what I'm
talking about so let's get it started
first of all let's go over some basic
definitions hi great greater than normal
and quantity size or intensity value the
regard of something held to deserve the
importance Worth or usefulness to
something and man an adult human male so
when you put all that together what do
you have an adult human male that's
greater than normal importance or
usefulness to what their group basic
economic principle states that the value
of something is what a market is willing
to pay for it the value is determined by
what the market and when we're talking
about individuals the market is other
people men or women so a high value man
is completely determined by the market
case in point you can have a vehicle a
home anything in your possession you can
hold it dear it could be supremely
important to you but when you put it on
the market the market decides and
there's an upper limit and a lower limit
it doesn't really matter if you think
the low is too low or the highest not
high enough that's what the market is
willing to pay for it and that is its
overall value that has been with us
forever so when we start talking about
that we're dealing with people it really
throws people off because it seems so
cold so calculated but like it or not
that's the way the world is so let's get
into this whole high value man thing
number number one in order to be a high
value man it starts with money again
like it or not I didn't put the six
figure thing out there it's been with us
since the mid 80s and like it or not
that's where this whole thing starts you
can't be high value and homeless so you
have to make a certain amount of money
and the line is roughly at ten thousand
dollars a month adjusted for Atlanta
dollars if you live in San Francisco L.A
New York City or the cost of living is
higher than 100 you need to adjust it so
ten thousand dollars a month gets the
starting point off for high value don't
shoot the messenger I'm just giving you
what the world gave me number two that
money needs to be made over a length of
time I.E performance and that's roughly
about five years and about the three
year mark you're kind of starting to
scratch the surface why does it need to
be five years well because guys it's a
matter of consistency and stability look
in the NFL the NBA anybody can have a
great season but having a great season
does not automatically mean you're going
to the Hall of Fame team they want to
see consistent numbers over a period of
time you know how this works just like I
do in business you can't be a one-hit
wonder or have up here and down there
consistency performance over a length of
time that's why their five-year Mark is
so important like I said around three
years you're starting to scratch the
subs but in five years people can pretty
much count on you to say this person
understands and knows how to get it done
number three is group acceptance like it
or not guys high value man is like a
fraternity it's like a club a secret
society and high value being no other
high value men then welcome them into
the group they know what it takes to be
there they know what it takes to get in
there and high value men group
acceptance is supremely important guys
secret societies fraternities
organizations have always been with us
and you know how this this works and
just general interaction guys that just
make their own secret society of Club
but it doesn't matter as much as
somebody says that group is important
guys this is about separation high value
men tend to huddle around other high
value men for reasons I'm going to go
into a little bit later but group
acceptance is another critical comp
another critical component of being a
high value man why is group acceptance
so important because the next part a
network you have to have a network of
other high-value men and others this is
another stumbling block for a lot of
guys for a lot of people because they
may have the money even the length of
time they may look like they fit the
group but if they don't even have any
other high value contacts or network a
group of others that person is going to
be looked at with a side eye think of it
like this if you're sitting at the table
with 10 high value men in each of these
10 men has 50 contacts that's 500
contacts and you sit at the table and
you have twice as much money as any
other man on there but you have zero
contacts what can you effectively get
done other than throw money at it these
other men can make phone calls exert
influence move things to get things done
and you can only do what you can only do
what offer money and potentially feed
off that network of contact one thing
high value men no one understands that
time is what's important and building a
network that actually works for you is
extremely important in some areas it's
called a book of business a book of
business can make you successful here
here and here your contacts your network
your network is your net worth you've
heard this before so you cannot
underestimate how important having a
network of high value men and other
people is to your status as a high value
man after the network we got to have the
visibility guys your income and your
position has to be LinkedIn level think
of it like this this person says they're
the CEO of a Fortune 500 company this
person is head of thoracic surgery at
Johns Hopkins this person is VP emerges
and acquisition at Bank of America and
then someone says hi I'm an entrepreneur
three of those four people at a glance
we can pretty much estimate who they are
what they do and their relative
importance in the overall socioeconomic
structure the fourth person more
information is needed it's not enough
visibility not enough transparency to be
a high value man it needs to be at a
glance again your your position and your
income guys you may have a lot of money
but if it's coming from sketchy areas no
one can kind of understand where it's
coming from that does not give other
high value men or even the public any
kind of real confidence that you are who
you say you are again guys it's about
the market it's what the market the
world is thinking they got to know at a
glance that you are a high value man and
the sixth part is probably my favorite
part guys a high value man is useful to
others and the group a lot of times you
hear people say I don't want to be used
I don't want to be used uh no I want to
be used why because that means I'm used
high value men are in demand and useful
their presence is felt when they're
there and they're absence is built when
they're gone that is how you know you're
really a high value man how you can move
things your ability to influence things
and that is your relative usefulness in
economics it's called utos how useful
are you to the group again there's no
high value homeless neither are there
any high value loners if you have all
these resources all this stuff but it's
all hoarded for your own selfish ends
and no one can benefit from your money
your network or anything you have how
valuable are you to the group to the
world to other people that's what this
comes down to high value men are in
demand and useful to other people as I
said
yeah I just don't think it like says
anything about women but that's are we
talking about alpha or are we talking
about high value
because we said that uh well for me an
alpha man is provision and protection
you can't be an alpha with one of those
missing and protection is as important
if not more because it signals more
survival than provision you can provide
all day every day but if you don't have
the strength or the ability to protect
the people that you care about you're a
pointless man
I think that's the important word the
people you care about because a lot of
these men like you said not everyone
that has a baby with someone might care
about but you should care about your
children no no no no no no no no no
mistakes happen yeah now momentum so so
okay so I think you're looking it from a
culture aspect and Community aspect yes
I actually believe everything that
you're saying but I just know in real
life men have always the top men have
always had loads of baby moms and gone
out there and they're not top men no
they are because they're not to really
disagree because it's like to me future
is not talking about the trash Tristan
Thompson
you're telling me he had more
reproductive success than anyone in all
of history you can't tell me he's not
the difference would be his women would
be submissive and loyal to him
absolutely of course and they belong to
everyone it's not a prize if everyone
can have it if I if I take if I take a
Chanel that everybody can have and it
becomes Primark it's no longer valuable
now if your woman is Primark and not
Chanel you are no longer expensive so
what you're saying if I've got five
wives yeah then I'm still Alpha I'm
still I'm still real to you then
submissive and loyal and uh like uh
modest absolutely but if they're five
hoes you're the idiot no I'm pretty sure
Genghis Khan had some bastards he had
hundreds he had hundreds of children
telling me he protected all of them with
anybody else okay so the women would not
they would be killed I think I think
you'll reach so basically a man can go
out here now yeah and have a hundred
like like 20 baby moms yeah yeah he one
of them baby mamas might have a kid by
another person that does not stop that
man from being the fact that he's going
out there in stool he's Alpha like I
hear what you think you're defining
Alpha by ability to have no because it's
not just that it's the ability to go out
there and to command women to come up
and still command men's attention and
still be strong woman can have sex with
any man no no no see the thing about us
men is yeah it's like especially if
she's a hoe so so a lot of shoes as well
I think you're confusing Alpha and high
value yeah like well um maybe but I I
think a high value is of no use if he's
not on Alpha no no no no no because
what's the point of a high value man if
you can't protect no because everybody
because every high value man is an alpha
so so let's take Kanye for example
absolutely maybe high value on this side
but he can't protect no one because he's
in like he's insane okay so he loses
like to me he loses he's not an alpha in
a room full of men
in the west men can't can't they can't
be out Alpha no no they they legally
can't yeah like like they've basically
in the west castrated man because it's
like how are they going to protect your
children when she can leave you and not
let you see your kids
like so how yeah like that's what you
pick why no no but but see that that
minimum but you're minimizing but that's
but that's this and you're like you're
minimizing what men go through women
women can wait stop you keep
interrupting me women can put on a show
women can completely trigger me like I
have seen girls oh come on you're
telling me none of you have seen a girl
that you would you would never know what
she has done and so so a good guy an
alpha man can still get tricked that can
still happen and so and so and so and I
agree if it keeps happening yeah like
but but the problem is it only takes one
time to ruin a guy
it only takes one time to to ruin a
guy's life where she can literally take
half and take the kids like how is he
supposed to protect the how is he
supposed to protect the children when
legally she can take them and she's paid
to take them away from him and have
another man move into the house yeah he
had to move out before the law is
absolutely disgraceful but just like you
were saying when we were talking about
women choosing men that are bad you're
exact words or you can't bamboozle me
more than once people men like who like
future and this like they've got or
hoses they're not being boozled they
just don't care yeah so therefore then
what you're saying doesn't apply to if
you have to have the same mentality for
both men and women
because because men and women are
different so I don't have the same I
don't have I don't have the same
mentality because men and women are
different women are born with value men
must create their value a guy doesn't
lose his value just because he picks the
wrong woman once apart from that men we
always adapt to whatever environment
they're playing picking the high value
men in the west have adapted to the way
Society is with women reach you have to
understand the way you're speaking is
yeah is if any one of us men speak like
how you're speaking Yeah do you know how
dangerous that is for us you can do it
no because you're a woman they can't
literally what do you mean no because
you're you're trying to remove basically
you're trying to save my throat to be an
alpha male yeah my woman can never leave
my house no matter what no no no no no
no no no no no no no no because you've
literally said you cannot be an alpha
from outside your home so if your woman
leaves you break it you're not an alpha
anymore that removes your Alpha so I
have to control my woman but we leaving
select wise no no no no no no see you
can't still select wisely and they still
follow yeah so you can't say that you
can't say [ __ ] off it's fine but [ __ ]
around we're not talking about [ __ ]
around like it keeps us so it's hard for
me to keep replying because it keeps
moving so it makes it hard for me to get
to make my points stick but initially we
was talking about one thing what makes
basically you're saying if you pick
badly or if you you said Tom Brady no
you said Tom Brady was an alpha because
he's getting divorced from Giselle
Giselle wasn't getting was because she
was out sleeping around she simply got
divorced because he said he wanted to do
another season in the NFL and she said
it was selfish so I didn't say because
she was sleeping around I said she's a
liberal woman a liberal woman's gonna
have liberals okay but once again once
again
so I don't think personally if I date a
supermodel I'm not talking about only
fans model yet oh but I don't consider
that's going to make me less of an alpha
I would think actually I'm picking yeah
in fact because they're back out logic
most high value men wouldn't be Alpha
because they date
yeah
the high value button Alpha man would be
a woman who's uh you won't know his
woman Leonardo DiCaprio had Jeff Bezos
is misses doing Madness in front of him
when she saw him like he's actually like
but Leonardo is lying he's Alpha come on
oh I love it man he can be Alpha I'm not
saying he's not Alpha but I'm just
saying to you that um you're defining
Alpha differently but I'll be honest
with you we Define it you don't you
don't no no we do we do I think your
definition of alpha is very unique to
you yeah
it's Universal it's provision and
protection in human nature it's only
changed in the West in Africa and if you
take people in their survival mode
people in survival mode food men have to
provide and protect women have to
nurture in survival mode that means it's
human can I ask you a question if two
men have a fight one man's girl is a
whole and one man goes not a whole the
guy whose goal is not a whole yeah
um he gets knocked out and the guy who's
uh whose woman is a is a 304 and she's
been outside and everyone knows her are
you gonna tell me the guy that got no
tax Alpha because he's his wife isn't a
whole another the guy that I'd say
they're both beat her uh no biggie so
see Alpha isn't that see so that's not
Alpha that's not how alpha Works see
Alpha is going to be the strongest guy
it's one of them they agree to disagree
but I think human nature and human
history and if you take uh all tribes
Across the Universe men masculinity and
Alpha is defined by provision and
protection and femininity is defined by
nurture we can argue and we can try and
out think some biology because
the guy that got knocked out would
actually end up losing his woman like so
this will happen right if that was
actually a tribe but the guy that stayed
with the home will end up being with a
woman
no he's gonna end up getting his woman
plus all the other women that's what
happened but it's only valuable if your
woman is loyal having a bunch of hoes is
not valuable no it's called a hair room
it's called having concubines you're
then looking after women that could
potentially it doesn't matter
so so the only thing that happens no the
only thing that matters is your day one
yeah these are side things I don't know
why we can't distinguish between this
throughout life men have had hordes of
women yeah these men have had hordes of
women these women have other things but
they can't out think biology you do know
that yeah but what I'm trying to say to
you is yeah if a man has got 20 women
yeah 19 of them are his concubines and
one of them is main day women he is
still an alpha man and if 19 of them are
cheating on him he's they can't cheat on
him because they're not his main they're
exciting okay but regardless no we're
not regardless he's got 20 women let's
say you've got 10 women in your home
yeah you're looking after all of them
they're in your home yeah you're feeding
all of them but this one's sleeping with
that guy this one's sleeping with that
guy that's gonna aren't you the idiot
that's paying her bills no but listen to
this
no but anyway it's not going to happen
of course
I know you're saying that Tom Brady is
an alpha because he picked a supermarket
most high value men date supermodels no
it's like very common
you're different I like her like I said
I I we can take high value in Alpha we
can agree they're different but I would
not say that all the men that you're
selecting as high value Alpha I don't
think Kanye is an alpha I do think
someone like Jay-Z is an alpha I think
he's more Alpha because his woman's on
smash you think Jace is more Alpha than
Kanye absolutely
wait wait wait wait but you won't send
me the whole album
[Laughter]
tonight okay
[Music]
um we're going to talk about something
else because I'm really bored of this
time okay
um do you guys think actually I'm gonna
Read Super chats first guys like the
video make sure you subscribe to the
channel okay the like is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push these videos out make sure you join
our membership so you can be a part of
the chat also guys um we have four
membership tiers the first you get to be
a part of the chat the second you get
are to be a part of our Discord and
behind the scenes Vlogs third you get to
connect with me on social media and
fourth you get a one-on-one call with me
once a month also guys make sure that
you follow my new Instagram it's just
pearly things one I think I just hit 2
000 followers so you could call me an
influencer
so okay so let's let's read the super
chats okay
um the oh wait hold on let me refresh it
because these are from yesterday
also guys let me know what you guys want
us to talk about Saturday because I was
trying to think of a show topic okay
Mark Perdue to be Alpha you command
respect and get compliance and Alpha
will wreck any high value man and Navy
SEAL versus Elon Musk Mark protrude high
value and Alpha are different with a
little overlap protection strength
leadership and wisdom determine Alpha
it's a term we use for Animals then we
apply it to ourselves no wolf or lion is
banging a corn star Andrew Cruz alpha
male is the one who does what he wants
always KCF say it with me a man sleeping
with you doesn't mean he chose you
um okay yama03 um good show Pearl I
agree with the lady guest in large part
part of the definition of alpha is
having respect of other men sure other
women may not mind but you can lose the
respective fellow high value men that's
the value you you lose Steve stoto yo
this woman on the panel belongs in the
Twilight Twilight Zone because her mind
is out there 90 free Tope Pearl is there
another way to chat you YouTube sensors
are whack AF I can't Super Chat anything
close to calling this female boring
except now
Frank the Tank happily married man three
kids since 19 years old for 20 years men
are called to lead but also to be led
alpha males will also learn to lead from
other Alphas love seeing these talks um
Casey afsack the chick keeps talking
about her Muslim culture but for some
reason she doesn't really look like
Fatima from for some wait but for some
reason she doesn't look like Fatima from
down the block and a mean Dana it comes
across overly presumptuous to tell men
how they should emote how men feel can
only be understood by other men ladies
you will never understand us stop what
the arrogance don't just don't assume
just ask Ezekiel Jesus wept multiple
times he was grieved so he wept crying
is only feminine in certain
circumstances Kerwin Thompson beard
gang's my boy but he's got to take this
L um Doug MPA beard game disappointing
us right now stop simping 93. why can't
women ever say I'm sorry with no butt um
amine Dana on pre-internet the nature
between men and women was not as
inflated because the amount of options
was limited to proximity to local now
they've been duped to think they
actually don't need to settle because of
the Endless Options what would something
I cannot say your name sir I'm very
sorry modern feminism is just another
branch of Marxism that is why you ask a
feminist what her political views are
she will always say socialism Doug MPA
women want credit for things they women
want credit for things they have the
possibility of doing not what they're
actually doing that's feminism big up to
ma ma oh my g China let's go yo my guy I
was like and he put hey I was like Mom
Let me refresh it and I'll read the rest
of the super chats
um to be Alpha you must come to be Alpha
you command respect and get compliance
and out oh I read that one already okay
okay guys make sure you like the video
um so my next question is marriage
outdated in 2022
why are you looking why are you
swallowing you look at me did you say
that I was looking at the panel actually
I looked at him too but I looked at both
of you because you're first no I just
okay she know what I think no you go you
go first no no it is I don't even know
what I think anymore these people been
just
out there I think the law has made it
really really unappealing for men I
think there's no need for a man I I I
know I keep going on about my religious
belief but if you've got religion I can
understand why you get married but even
then I don't think you should do it
legally but if you haven't got any
religious reasons or anything like that
I don't understand why anybody man or
woman would get married because it's
it's designed to make you turn against
each other the law just puts you against
each other and it's a horrible way to do
it would you have a family without
marriage not without an Islamic one
though but without illegal yeah okay
absolutely what about you two
um personally
um religious wise I feel like yeah
marriage is is needed but you need to
um commit to someone in the eyes of God
you know what I'm saying and in front of
your people that you know I'm saying you
know you know what I'm saying and so you
dedicate to each other it's more like a
um how can I say it's I think it's more
official that's that's why I feel anyway
I think no idea of it's nice if you're
lucky enough to find someone that you
can just fully trust and be here forever
then great but
obviously for a lot of people it doesn't
work out I mean
I'll just say
um
I think it's just the Western problem
really and truly
um
I believe if you're in a society where
um religious values or any sort of
um General consensus where people have
um equal values and set rules I think in
that kind of society yeah you can
probably make it work but in a society
where we have the kind of settings where
women are paid to leave that kind of
thing and all of that it just makes it
really really hard because you could you
could literally have a good marriage
going and then years down the line
something happens and then the woman
sees as an opportunity to leave and
that's how we see the billionaires
coming out in the
I'm curious from the man
do you guys want to get married
so um yeah um you know I want to get
married like so but
the management knows I want to get mad
they're not full marriage over here but
I'll explain so basically I
ever since we started I spent about it I
was talking about the other options I
think I've been more open to some of the
other options like what you're saying as
well about me married in the in a
religious way but maybe not like that
legal way whatever only because of all
the stories and everything that goes
with it but I believe in institutional
marriage and what it represents and the
family unit because my parents have been
married over 40 years I got um
four other siblings they're all married
an older child so I come from that unit
so I'm the only one that's not married
so I do believe in it but I just think
the more and more I do this and the more
and more I probably listen to people and
the people that I've been married you
know people that have come in with good
intention and but then again like King
was saying over there like I just think
in a western world when you have these
Traditional Values and stuff it makes it
a lot harder for you to to move
um and you just got to be aware that if
you
yeah if you do think like this not
everyone's gonna think like that you
know and I I have because I've been in
this a little bit longer so I'm hearing
stories of 20 years 30 years
everything's been good and then people
are saying oh you don't know what she's
done to me
so we just kind of I don't know man I
just
like yeah I guess it's a risky it's a
risk in it it's a risk it's a risk but I
think sorry Paul um what you said before
when we spoke about you said for average
men I think is a very bad like it's not
as good but if you're a
multi-millionaire yeah it's gonna hurt
you but billing you're likely to to be
all right after that and come back but
for someone that you know they haven't
got got to say um the same resources and
then they get divorced at 50 55 and she
takes half and then they have to now
work and you know these are some of the
things that can lead to male suicide and
the stress of it or you know what I mean
so I just think yeah it's a quite a
precarious one
I'd like to get married but I need to be
at a certain point in life before I can
do that I mean like you said if things
go badly you want to know that it's not
going to impact you to the point where
you're down and out so that if it does
go wrong you've still got enough to just
continue and also I think obviously if
you've got kids or if you want to have
kids it plays a big part because I
definitely believe in
I never grew up in that kind of
household but I always felt like I would
have liked to have grown up in a
household with two parents that I
married don't actually see that so I'd
like to give my kids that one so bro
um can I just ask you um what what did
you feel that was missing and what did
you feel like at the time of other
friends that had that
just felt like uh just left out and just
like a bit envious yeah little things
like Christmases birthdays where you've
got to choose which parents house you've
got to go to all that kind of stuff it's
just a lot nicer to be in a family unit
and seeing like friends that go home and
they've got their mum and dad in the
same household and it's just when you're
growing up you kind of wanting that but
you can't so I don't know I'd like to
give my kids that
I just you know what it is because I've
had the two pair at home and I know how
it's shaped how I look at things and how
I come into the world it's just that I
always like to ask other people because
I've had my friends that's hard growing
up without it yeah definitely
definitely especially if your parents
don't get on that's the worst because my
mum and dad didn't get on why not for
all throughout my childhood so there was
always constant battles of
which parent do you prefer kind of thing
and that impacts the kid you know what I
mean because
you'd end up feeling guilty a lot of the
time I forgot to choose I got I forgot
to stay with my dad I'll stay with my
mom or
so it's it's uncomfortable dude and you
don't have to say this if you don't want
you did both of your parents do it
what'd you mean I've just found that
like women seem to do that more did you
find that both they both did it they
both hated each other equally how how
would they put you in the middle of it
uh
the little thing well mainly mainly
disrespecting each other to me or in
front of me that was the main thing that
I mean like they'll be bitching about
each other to me and I'm just like why
are you telling me for I'm the wrong
person
that was the main thing I think
and it kind of it only really stopped as
I got older and then I I was able to
actually level with them and say like
this is ridiculous you need to stop I
mean and then I think my parents were
really young when they had me as well
like 18 and 21 so they were kids while
we were trying to raise a kid so they
were doing really immature [ __ ] while I
was growing up it's only when they got
older and more mature and wiser than
they actually saw actually this is not
the right way to do things so
we all kind of grew together really
no I've I've heard that's really common
where like the they'll put the kids in
the middle of it it's not fair to the
kids nah nah I was the only child who's
all growing up so it was definitely it
was literally the all of the focus was
on me
did you did your mom have a did you have
a stepdad figure at home or anything
that too as well so my mom had a
boyfriend from when I was young but then
I never really got on with him because I
knew my dad didn't like him so there was
an instant friction yeah did I mean I
even saw them beefing at one point so it
was all like it was very very messy very
messy so um do you have any sorry to ask
do you have any half sisters I got
horses though how did you feel he
treated you versus his his own
uh no difference no difference no
but again there's this my sister was
born when I was 11. okay so it was like
I was then raising her with him kind of
yeah yeah I mean it went like a mm-hmm
competition type
did your mom give him like full
authority to like discipline you or was
that a form of friction too
full of worry but he didn't need to if
anything
do you know what it is yeah it's like
with my dad there was a level of
understanding I never crossed the line
with him because I was just more afraid
of seeing him angry whereas my mom she
more than the disciplining but it was
more over the top so I mean like the
Beats all that kind of stuff which is
like
I mean we've all gone through it you
know I mean it's funny that you say that
yeah and like the same thing with my mom
my dad my dad's never hit me in his life
my dad didn't need to hit me either but
I knew but I knew I didn't want to ever
get to that point and and but my mom for
her whole life would tan me and I'll I
would go back out and do the same thing
yeah the only time that it actually got
to me is when she started learning about
I'm gonna ground you and do some
psychology that was like the worst like
you know like she's like you can't go
and see your friends I was like No just
hit me like
but I've I've discovered something that
that that
which a lot of men don't want to they
don't want to admit because they don't
wanna they don't like saying things
about their mom but we get more Trauma
from our mothers than I feel that we get
from our fathers and if we look at all
the women that are bringing up these
these kids now that doing all the
madness things a lot of them don't have
the father figure and I think the things
that I've struggled with
in my life
um well when my father wasn't around and
my dad my both my parents were together
but because of his job he was always in
the home so it doesn't matter if your
parents are actually together if he's
not in the home your parents are not
together you're not trying to say to you
because you need to have a man that's in
the home like what you saying so my
dad's job he was always flying across so
what I think is
um when you're growing up as a teen and
then you have a lot of um you have a lot
of testosterone and the same thing um
what's the what's the one that women
produce sorry estrogen estrogen right so
you're being brought by women and I
think a lot of single single mothers
feminize their boys and they don't
actually realize they do it so as you're
growing up you're struggling with your
emotions and now it's quite angry
um and that's the point where a man
would tell you as a man how to handle
these emotions right but you don't have
a man in the home you have a woman that
loves you but she's you know Mommy and
you're making your boy when you have
these boys that go into the world and
they get angry they don't have to handle
the emotion this is a lot of the times
what you hear that these kids do mad
thing and you're like you see I I think
the main thing when parents are not
together is that there's an equal split
of time spent so like for me I was with
my mom in a week but with my dad at the
weekend so that was very much equal
amount of time spent about you but you
hear these stories where kids don't see
their dads for weeks and months mine was
longer because it was he was an African
who's back on forth so it was always
that thing where yeah he was fully in my
life and he's there he's at home now my
mom's in that but he wasn't there
because of his job he was always moving
back and forth so I just found that that
I suffered for some of the things that
probably some of the other people suffer
from from not having the father that's
there every day he's there but he's not
there every day but your mom's there and
mother's put us through some next
emotional stuff but but for some reason
we we always like try to be like I want
to help my mom but we forget about the
dads but when I look at most of the
trauma that's gone through even with
women women throw out their sons all the
time women throughout their daughters
it's very rare that a man would throw
out his daughter or his son because he
would think about all the things that
potentially could happen to his son or
his daughter that's really true I don't
know I'm single I only know everyone I
mean I don't know many people that were
thrown out but the ones that I do I'm
like they were it was always the mother
I think that's just because when women
just act off emotion and men think most
logically so in that instance a man
logically thinking is going to think I'm
not gonna throw my you out because
like bad [ __ ] can happen whereas a woman
might just be acting emotionally at the
time
my mother's feel about treating us a
certain way but we still love them then
we go seeking out the women that will do
similar things as well that will hurt
you and do certain things that you don't
understand why men do this but if you
look at the relationship that some other
some of us had with our mothers and I
love my mum to bits but I'm just talking
about a lot of times women don't realize
that when you're over
um feminize your boys you don't realize
that the boys are supposed to be
masculine and they're supposed to be
learning how to deal with masculinity
and how to deal with their anger issues
and their emotions but when you have a
boy that's in his teens and it hasn't
been taught how to handle his emotions
and he reacts women dealing emotion us
men we think and when you do something
in Emotion that's how you end up doing a
crazy thing and now you're in jail so I
just think that people that's what
happens you know what I mean and it's
just that I think like you know we just
don't speak about some of these things
and the more and more I've been on these
platforms and speaking is I think a
little bit more I'm starting to
understand myself a bit better as well
Paul one thing's about to selected
separately do you think getting beats as
a kin impacted you negatively or
positively
another one
you know what I think it is I think
because we We're Men you know even
amongst men you know that threat of
violence is always there and even with
boys they can feel it so when a child is
with his Dad he can always feel that
threat of violence if he's messing up
but with women that thing is not there
so it's not real so they have to
actually resort to actual violence
would you hit your kids would you hit
your kids no I really didn't like it I
think for men it's good it kind of I
know it kind of prepares them a bit for
that uh level of you can only get away
with so much before we start throwing
hands but for women it just uh we don't
need that it's harder with girls we
don't need that skill it's not a
transferable skill whereas for you guys
it does toughen you up but for us it's
not a transferable skill we don't need
that in the real world and what it
actually does is makes you her quick to
anger in the real world and I didn't
like it like my mom always always kind
of like she'd always throw hands and
stuff and I felt like it actually did
lead to me being more masculine when I
get into conflict which I don't think is
a good thing
yeah Paul I
so there's a level of African boots
that's just extreme
is is but discipline is needed but I
just think there was a level like
because it's mad because my mum how
she's with the grandkids I like they
always suffer it's so it's so weird to
me the way the thing she lets them get
out oh don't hit your kids so I'm like
what Mom the woman that disciplined us
and did all these things now you're with
the grandkids
she just lets him she's like no no let
him beat so I just think that I would do
a level of discipline like if they're
young and they wanna if there's a plug
there and they're gonna do something
different or pick up a knife or you know
I mean don't do that but the one where
you go out and pick it no no no no no no
no I'm not doing that I'm curious where
did you say you were from again Pakistan
Pakistan what is there the same problem
with modern women there that we have
here
um I think it's getting there because uh
social media is so globalized so they're
starting to pick up the same morals and
values uh it's not quite there yet it's
still very much men and men and women
are women um the ones that live in
Britain or in the US they're totally
like the westerners um and this might be
ignorant but is this that Muslim yeah
okay yeah so are you cool like with the
can you you can have three wives we can
have four wives my dad um my dad has two
wives so yeah
interesting what was that like I really
liked it I mean it's not it wasn't easy
for everybody but
um yeah so like what
um I have a family I have four brothers
and sisters in Pakistan and I've got me
and my five in uh England and um we
didn't know for quite a bit of our lives
and then we kind of got introduced later
on and so on and so forth well you
didn't know we didn't know for a little
while wait how because I think my mom
was trying to Shield us from it because
it's so unfamiliar to her but it was
familiar in my dad's kind of like a
region where he's from and she was kind
of shielding us from it but then we
wanted to introduce and blend the
families out I really like the idea of
having extra siblings and um but my
dad's mainly with us but what I found
hard is how much he just couldn't split
his time equally it was so much more
close to us than he was with them so
it's almost a bit difficult to watch how
they've got a completely different
father than we have so where did they
live they live in Pakistan oh and we
live in England oh I didn't I didn't
realize okay obviously by Coastal so
then when when did that split like when
did you guys move well my dad grew up in
Pakistan had kids everything then came
to England and then met my mom and then
got married and all these things we say
it's because of the passport you know we
don't want it
um but you know so and then he just
started a family with my mum and uh and
that's just but he goes back and forth
and then we're all friends like yeah but
you were the second family though yeah
so we were kind of but you kind of were
the first in a way like you spent more
time with you yeah we're the second
family but you get more of the yeah you
get more treatment if I'm honest and so
not fair and he's still married
do they do they get jealous my mom does
my mom does um yeah because she's she
came here when she was she's 14.
attention so she she gets such a good
life but she's far more because she came
here when she was 14 so her values are
different whereas the one in um in
Pakistan her values are just accepting
that this is what a lot of men just go
to a different country does she not know
initially she did know
but she just is so jealous regarding it
whereas it just shows you how cultural
it is because the other one because it's
so part of their family and their
culture she's so okay with it but with
my mum because it's not part of her
family and not part of her culture she's
so not okay with it even though she gets
a far better end of the deal so it I
guess it's because I'm very possessive
and jealous as well even with my partner
and I think it must be conditioned in me
because I see other cultures and they
actually just get on with it would you
accept it no no I I don't know I maybe I
would if it was like if I was the second
one of this Sunday I think the first one
would be really difficult to accept that
yeah
um but yeah no I don't think I would I
oh yeah I don't think I would but you
never you never know God might test you
differently I saw a comment the other
day
um and I I have no idea if this is true
I just read a comment they said muslim
girls are the new Catholic girls okay
and so like basically saying that
feminism is kind of seeping into that
Community too and you're starting to get
would you say that's true absolutely
because I deal with a lot of clients and
a lot of my um clients are men Muslim
men and uh the treatment that they get
from their it's it's different because
before it would be like the culture I
was raised it's like my brother gets a
completely different treatment to us so
we cook clean everything and we do
everything for him he doesn't have to do
any of that and we're okay with that
we're totally fine with that but now
we're living in a world where that scene
is so unfair whereas we kind of accept
it because we wouldn't pay for anything
uh but we would do all the chores and we
just accepted that Dynamic but now the
culture is you're getting to a Muslim
man and a Muslim woman raised in the
same home but getting a totally
different experience and getting really
resentful about that so the girls are
seeing that and thinking that's unfair
the men are just used to it and this
building that resentment whereas we just
accepted that's part of our upbringing
so I think it is becoming really angry
feminists now
that's interesting I've only met like
one or two people that had that multiple
words is it common like it's not is it
coming in like where you guys are from
it's so common my dad can have it but my
mom wouldn't have it yeah
she can but my mom is very Western so
she wouldn't she wouldn't sit for it
yeah oh yeah I wonder then does that
mean jealousy is something we condition
or like no just like it's just you have
to know the wife you marry like some
women will will be okay with that some
of them won't well I think it's like
women we don't want the it's like the
biological reason is we don't want the
resources to go to someone else so
that's like why if a girl catches it
like a guy cheating it's like do you
love her where if a guy catches a girl
cheating like don't guys ask like where
they slept together and all this stuff
like was was he bigger was he I mean I
don't no I've never been you'd be more
okay do you think women would be more
okay with two wives rather than just a
man that constantly has like what do you
think it would be better for women I
mean I think the two wives would be
better but I think modern women are
Sideshow I think modern it's like
situation chips and what's a
situationship you're sharing a guy so
earlier when I said what do women share
men is like your family is an example
and your dad is one of the men that has
access to these men these men out there
that can't get one but that has two
families
provided they provided for both of them
yeah they don't work yeah so so what's
it what it says again if you can provide
yeah there'll be women out there that
are not going to be bothered because in
reality women are not bothered but they
just have to there's there's a certain
cost for the what's the word for the
submission right here yeah
and that's all it is like there's a
little and some of us we can't access
some of us you know we can't we don't
have the fun for that submission and
other people do and so that's why if
you're when women say oh
if a man pulls up in a Lamborghini and
then you discover he does something and
you say I'm going to leave you I didn't
see it
you he's
going to be changing your life listen
you're gonna walk in watching him
bending a girl over and you're still not
going to see it literally it's gonna be
like I'm blind I'm blind this barking
I'm blind
when you get married do you want to be
monogamous yeah like like so I like
there's no point in being married if I
still want to be outside right because I
can just be outside in it I do believe
like at some point as a man it gets
boring you're gonna find it boring you
like you want one woman and all of that
stuff and also if I have a children I
just don't want to be out there like on
their mother but
I just like yeah like because if you
leave it long enough then you don't need
to be outside normal but if you want to
be outside be outside like you don't
have to if you don't want to be married
don't be married just be in a
relationship and this I think today
there's so many different types of
relationships you can have Pearl I don't
think anyone has to kind of just have
you can basically have whatever you want
like you just have to find the people
for it right like like going to the
communities this whole poly hashtags
nowadays you know what I mean like if
you want that don't go get a girl which
you're gonna destroy your whole life and
then ruin how she thinks about men it's
just fighting a woman which doesn't mind
and then so China do you count like you
know like so if a man is
he's gotten his his woman he's faithful
and all that so do you count the
occasional times when he kind of trips
and falls into the vaginas
well you know what it is
there was an episode I was like what did
you do triple fall in this dick and he's
like oh now he's like he's switching it
right he's like whatever man trips or
forces that occasional trip
unfortunately
do you count that has been outside
that's not being outside oh so look I'm
gonna just put I'll be like this so like
40 year marriage he hooks up with a
couple you know a girl every couple of
years another one so at this point like
if your wife if you're telling your
wifey it's good so if telling your wife
he's gonna cause you to destroy your
relationship then you know what you're
doing in it I just think
friends do stuff loving their misses and
acting like they don't and then they do
something they get caught and they lose
their misses and it destroys a man's
life don't be one of those guys so yeah
so whatever you do you prepared for in
it because
it is you might be in the comments
crying about oh my wife is taking half
in it you know what I mean so I just
yeah you need to know the type of
relationship you have because some women
will allow that one woman you do that
once she's taking everything so you have
to know the type of woman that you have
it's your type of woman that will
forgive you will forgive it's the type
of woman that's going to be like you
know as long as it wasn't the resources
she's gonna ask you so what did you do
what have you been buying this girl
stuff you know like if you discovers
that you know you've been paying for a
flat you bought you've been dude like
she might say okay now I want to take
take half but if she just knows that it
was one of those things she'd be like
you know I don't want to split up the
family the kids don't have to know go
buy me some maybe you have to go and do
some stuff to to make up for it but I
just think man them whatever you do just
just do it with your chest honestly I
don't I don't understand like I don't
understand it how like guys will have
the time and the energy to like live two
lives we're like it's different if
you've got two wives and everyone knows
everything like but when you know when
like guys literally live like a whole
life you know what I mean like they'll
have a whole family on the side and it's
just that level of stress like you're
not trying to accomplish anything in
your life like I met um I met a guy that
he told me he was the youngest in his
family
and he had four older siblings
and he said my older sibling is from a
different woman because his his um
father got the side chick pregnant and
the mom stayed with him and was
literally there when the side chick gave
birth Madness wait was this my was this
my boy
you don't know no no do you know why
because I literally know there's a same
story the same story no no but it's
literally I mean this was in the U.S no
this is the UK yeah yeah yeah yeah I I
was like oh my God that like that is
another level
good woman when I say good woman I don't
mean like when people say oh he's a real
man for stepping up but I just mean some
women would love you so much that
they're gonna like you know what I mean
like I mean I think I could get over a
lot but oh my God that's like a kid that
would be that would be hard that would
be a kid you're breaking up your family
bro
ideally I like to think I wouldn't but I
think it would be really hard for me to
actually forgive a guy that he got
another girl pregnant it's just the
irresponsibility of it like if you're
gonna do it at least like don't get
another girl pregnant yeah like any of
the drama I just yeah I think that would
really piss me off but I think I think
it's probably because
um if there's no kid involved you guys
can pattern it and kind of lie but once
as a kid
you gotta introduce the kid to like the
family
tell your sisters I live a little
stressed man I can't even imagine like
how hot your head would be at that point
I
I mean that I think would be really hard
to forget would you accept if he's just
stepping up but not uh getting anyone
pregnant
do we have kids no
oh no kids I mean were we are we married
no you're in a relationship oh um
that's an interesting question I I like
to say no but I think if I'm being truly
honest with myself for the right guy I
probably would and I let I like to think
I wouldn't oh how many times
oh how many times how many laugh lines
does he get
um
I think if it's like uh we're not even
married yet he's already doing it
um I think if it's like this is all okay
this is all like a prediction yeah and I
just know that like
for the right guy that I would put up
with a lot and I think most girls for
the right guy would put up with a lot I
don't know how many times does it
disqualify him from being the right guy
if he's doing that to me it would
um I like that in I the idea of it but I
just think I'm being real when I say
um I don't know the right guy could get
away with a lot what about they were all
hot chicks he was who are you quoting
with like you looked at them when you
was like yeah they were super hot
um
oh God I don't know this is all like a
prediction right like
um for a small part of you might respect
him more if they're like yeah
I guess if they were whales
which is usually the case to be fair
when guys step out it's usually for
girls it's just like I've witnessed
other girls and it's like and they've
stayed for the right guy and I've stayed
before when someone like cheated and so
it's like how can I say I wouldn't if I
did and also I remember my mom said this
to me when I was younger I didn't
understand it um because one of my
sisters was was dating someone and she
was like oh mom was like I've got
someone from Africa for you and you
should try to hook her up I'm like Mom
she's got a man like what are you doing
she's like mom's like
um like so what that's just a boyfriend
what does it matter in it and I never
understood it about that time but you
know when I say it's not it's not yours
it's just your turn it's literally
that's all it is the only reason that
women have body counts is because
they've been with all these typical guys
that did not actually turn out to be
anything that was going to be anything
tangible so
if a girl says I've got a man and she
hasn't got a ring she's open game
everyone's open game you you haven't
like and it's the truth for the matter
you might not like it yeah yeah sorry
sorry oh yeah but it's just that if you
haven't got a ring and you're not mad
you're single and that's how the
government looks at it and that's how
people look the only reason I won't
speak to you when you're outside is if I
have a ring on your finger I know some
people will but the one way to guarantee
that you will not get attention is when
a man looks and he sees a ringer but
like she's taken apart from that
everyone's free game
I just think that like as women were
attracted to certain type of guys and
you know if a guy has all the like all
the things that you look for he might
cheat yeah so how can I how can I be
that mad if he cheats when it's like I
picked him but I think it takes quite a
secure woman to be able to actually
forgive it I I know it sounds
counterproductive but if you've got
secure in yourself and you can forgive
really easily I think you'll be able to
forgive it but I think if you're really
insecure it just ignites your
insecurities even more and then it falls
apart so it actually makes you more
secure for staying I think yeah well I
think the K I don't know if I could do
the kid I think that would be very cool
I don't know where the line is but I
think it's a child it's like it's like
for men like they're also a woman
cheating me now she's out the door but
then I don't have kids the one when I
say she had kids it's one of those ones
then we then we say oh sorry then we say
um okay has was it is it public is it
embarrassment you start trying to damage
control because you're thinking right
what can I well how can I say face what
can we recover from here because we have
kids right but if you don't have kids
I'm gonna be outside but if we do have
kids I'll be real with you I'll be
thinking more about trying to trying to
but what can I do where at that point
you'd probably start stepping out though
it would be like yeah oh yeah
all right I'll forgive you like no one
knows I'll forgive you but like yeah
we'll turn into whole swingers over here
we're dropping our keys in the bow
everything I have a different opinion on
when women cheat especially in a
marriage though yeah because I feel like
when a woman cheats in a marriage that
that is more than just emotions and I
feel like
there is that element of her not really
understanding how dangerous a man's life
is in terms of the fact that you're
going to go and sleep with another man
when you have your whole family with a
different man that's like that's like
literally
starting like a wall
but I think yeah at least with me with
women I think you can actually prevent a
woman from cheating but I don't think he
can prevent a man from cheating please
tell me how you could prevent it I think
a man can be very happy and satisfied
and still step out but I think with a
woman the moment she feels some neglect
that's when her things are heightened
when she's not neglected she's tends to
be more loyal neglect leads to I think
when women cheats because they think
they can do better but I think neglect
determines whether they think they can
do better I think a man that's not
neglecting you you think okay I'm upset
but when he starts neglecting you you
think I can do better I just I think
you're either that guy to hurry or not I
think it also depends on the type of
girl in it like if she's got her
Tendencies and you marry her
like she might not even feel neglected
but she's just
maybe because the career I do I work
with couples and stuff a lot but I see
men who are millionaires and they're why
lives are cheating with like a guy who's
got a bed set in like a Camden or
something that's too horny and no no
because she just needed to feel because
he was out
because she married the guy for the
resources and she wanted the sex when a
woman hasn't been given attention I'm
not saying it's a good thing but I just
think women are so attention driven that
when if you give her enough attention
she'll manage no no no no no because
what you're doing is you keep removing
it's like we have to give him an
accountability women married these guys
for resources yeah it was never the guy
which which set heart on fire but she
married for since remember I said she
married what makes sense right now the
problem with when you marry for what
makes sense and even when you're married
condition Hall it doesn't matter if he's
20 years at some point she can step
outside because she has it inside what
did she think she was marrying if he's
like like that that's the sorry I'm
sorry that just sounds so stupid to me
like from from her the girl who says
that because it's like my mom's married
to that guy my dad would go to India for
weeks at a time trying to get build
their company up but she knew he was a
workaholic you can't have like women
like we think we can have everything and
now you're gonna say oh I'm neglected
because my husband's going to work to
provide for my fan family so I'm gonna
cheat that's the most [ __ ] that's
the stupidest thing I've ever document
but it is and I don't want to think like
my mom is and I would never do this to a
woman like what what I've seen my
parents sacrifice for us for this first
generation is it's things that people
could never even do now because the
selfishness and you know I mean I
watched my parents live in two separate
countries still together but because of
that they gave their five children the
best opportunities to come into this
country as the first generation from
Cameroon right so it's like it's like
by what you say my dad fully neglected
my mom you know what the difference is
there though they had a joint Mission
yeah they're literally they had a common
goal and they were both working towards
certain in your example it's the woman
just marrying for resources that's
that's shallow but I would say that the
same thing like when a man has a woman
that's looking after their kids and
doing all of that being and then he
steps out because he just wants to have
sex isn't that just equally as [ __ ]
it's not the same thing I think the same
would be him funding another woman yes
that's that's more yeah yeah so wouldn't
that be the case if a woman is at like
how a man's providing for you and you're
just because you feel neglected and
you're cheating which I think is
ridiculous but it does happen
um wouldn't it be the same kind of
philosophy when a woman's looking after
your kids and being loyalty and cleaning
your house and cooking for you and
because she's not as sexy as she used to
be you're stepping out no do you know
the same disrespect no I think the
equivalent is him spending money on
another girl having a full side chick
that he pays her right I think that is
take a dent in your pocket though no
even the fact that if you're taking
resources
because at that moment you know like
see at that moment you know it's more
than that like I never understand when
guys got girls and they step up but they
don't just step out Pearl they actually
have like they start taking girls on
dates and stuff I'm like bro what are
you that's what I was saying earlier
like it's Madness
how do you have enough energy to be
dealing with that but the reason they do
this is because like their home lights
are [ __ ] boring and they ruin a
boring and women looking after their
kids no but yeah but you're boring
they're going to meet a girl and she's
exciting right if he starts financially
funding her says you know I'm gonna pay
for you your studies yo he's cheating in
a different way how do I say it's not
about better it's just about different
yeah and there's nothing there's nothing
wrong you can't stop a man because they
dislike varieties no but if we look at
if it works so if when your wife cheats
on you it's so much deeper because in
order for a woman to do that she has to
have some type of emotion some women on
demon time yeah and we don't really talk
about those women because those are the
women that will just do whatever right
but what generally
to make your misses that loved you and
was only sleeping with you to go and
open her leg so next your missus is gone
she's not coming back your man's gonna
go do that he's gonna get post not
Clarity he's like oh my God I love my
girl let me go buy it
yeah but you can't equate it sexy in in
infidelity the same not to men not to
men because then what's gonna happen is
but how could you you had to have been
turned on by her to be no men who were
hole in the wall and I'm not trying to
make it better I'm just trying to say
I'm trying to say he's different so if
you judge yourself by that you'll never
understand why he can truly love you and
cheat yeah like you know what I mean do
you think there's certain cultures of
men that cheat more than others or do
you think it's all men I don't think
it's so this whole I I think that
certain types of men cheat more so like
if you're gonna date an NBA player or
um and like you know versus like the
computer nerd I feel like the community
computer nerd is less likely to do it
that pretty boils down to options though
again
like the NBA player is going to have mad
options so it's a lot more difficult for
him not to cheat I don't know I just
like you know you get these guys that
say I've never cheated in my life I've
never stepped out but I'm like
you actually can't even if you want to
you know even if you wanted you actually
can't go and draw another girl but like
for the guys that have girls throwing
themselves at him it's a lot more
difficult no you're right I think that
like like take Tiger Woods
and I used to I used to disagree with
this but then I was like you know what
if most guys had a Bus full of models
begging to sleep with them at the end of
the of a long hard day at work are they
gonna say no for 40 50 probably not it's
probably even a good man like one day
he's just gonna be like you know what
she's hot they're ready and her Tiger
Woods the situation as well like going
golf Gophers there traveling all around
the world
you know I mean
it's the fact that he was doing that and
he was still had a top game could you
imagine how the levels he was he was
literally dealing with all these women
and he was just knock it in the hole
yeah this guy's a g we got Tiger Woods
man definitely new maybe it motivated
him like he was like I need to get more
models but like yeah no like yeah like
no um for so I actually think when most
when these men cheat you know they don't
cheat because they want to cheat right
I'm not taking the responsibility away
from them but men are weak and women
know how women are
some women can be so what's the word
unoffensive like they're so forward
didn't it and when you put a man that's
got these status got this Cloud got his
riches the types of women that go up to
him like you know men yeah like you know
and then some you know used to always
get caught like Ashley Cole and John
Terry you will see the woman that would
cheat with and you'll be like bruh you
just wouldn't understand it man that's
the worst day when you realize you have
to worry about ugly girls too you're
like oh my God
ugly ugly fat girls that can cook you
need to worry about these women with
good attitudes oh hey these are the this
is the one that you slim women need to
worry about this is all you buy it's
hard as a woman because you can be
everything and you can still get that's
still an option like you you can still
cheat and that's not a problem so that's
why it's a bit harder in that sense but
I also think here it's the west Western
like sit Pearl when did it become
cheating when did it change from like
pulling me to monotona when did it
because what do you mean like
because I know it wasn't always like
this I knew like at different times
people used to get on like one man would
you know have certain woman some men
wouldn't get women and that's just how
it was well the divorce rate skyrocketed
with the development of birth control
um and that's like when the divorce rate
started to happen
so the 60s yeah so we need to get rid of
birth control
well I mean they've been taking me
don't tempt me no but what I've
discovered about birth control is that
it's like I didn't know it made girls
moot now I discovered it changes the
type of guy you're attracted to too so
you're more attracted like it your body
is pregnant so it tricks your butt like
that's how you don't get pregnant
because your body into thinking you're
pregnant so what happens is like then
when a girl's pregnant she's looking for
more of a provider guy so she might pick
a guy and then get off of birth control
and not even be attracted to her husband
I've I've heard stuff like I've heard of
that yeah yeah it's black I just know
like in like with my goal in that yeah
she said like she don't she don't take
those stuff and then that was the first
time I probably you know like because
all the other women that I've dealt with
I've dealt with birth control and
they're crazy so I think it um
so when I hear that and and I think it
makes sense because when they say I
don't want to take that because I don't
wanna and it can make me not like you I
heard that what do you mean you could
make me not like yeah you might just
turn around I don't like you anymore
yeah because it changes the type of guy
you pick and you're attractive I thought
she was Captain when she said no that's
true
that's true so I mean you could argue
that the divorce rate went up I saw a
theory about this the other day and I
thought it was interesting that maybe
the divorce rate went up because girls
are on birth control when they picked
their husbands and then after they got
the kids they weren't attracted to them
anymore
I don't know if that's true it's just a
theory I heard yeah I don't want to
remind them don't risk it don't start
gonna
imagine she just comes off it and when
they realizes like I don't actually like
you're ugly
it's hard it's not it's a hard one don't
it because it's like it's like kids no
kids like it's difficult unless you want
to be just cheating with condoms the
whole time which is slowly no idea
but you know you're supposed to do it I
saw um I posted it on
that thing when that girl was talking
about oh yeah
um every guy I had sex with I had sex
with my period that's disgusting yeah
yeah she's like and I was like oh that's
a whole blood ritual there that's all
sacrifice but you do realize that's what
they used to do in the olden days that's
how they guaranteed not you're not
getting pregnant and that they would
have sex during the period and when you
wanted to get pregnant is when you have
sex I swear you can still get pregnant
because it's impossible shoot up in the
club of sort of heard yeah okay um
marriage causes divorce says ex-wife
taking half half is the biggest myth in
the UK manosphere the UK family courts
normally give out 70 to the ex-wife
where kids are involved Ali M women need
to respect men and let them be the man I
can't stand the one women who are
controlling in relationships don't don't
get the urge to be don't you get the
I can't stand the ones who are
controlling in a relationship and get
the urge to be on the man's level
marriage causes divorce marriage is
imaginary it's just a piece of paper but
with massive Financial consequences I
lost 70 percent of my money and Assets
in my divorce the UK Court divorce
courts are ruthless please China don't
do it that's what I mean they're trying
to save me yeah
zero Fallout what do you think about it
you know
show you know it was paid with me you
know I dm'd you like and I spoke to a
few people in the comments and I just
was open to to listen to other to other
to the other side I'm still open to like
the whole
um ceremony thing but I just think I'm
you know yeah the comment section talk
to you out of marriage I'm not gonna say
a little bit no they just made me
they're just telling me just to look at
all aspects of it and there's a lot of
men in there that actually came and told
me their stories of what they calling it
going through so they haven't had a few
people that call me Sim look I've never
received the one thing I'm not doing
which camera is it blessing that camera
I'm not simping like you guys I'm just
remember my upbringing and my family and
my sister's like is you know we all have
different things it's okay so
statistically kids do better in marriage
yeah like yeah like you know why are we
so stuck on this men versus women kids
matter more yeah I just I'm like I'm
just I I came in you know the dad is in
financial ruins because the woman
laughed yeah I just I came in very very
tunnel vision with it and I think I
wasn't given enough like to listen to
other people's what they've been through
in it so yeah yeah um zero zero Fallout
one marriage in the west is done don't
XX don't learn until disasters affect
affect them you want someone to go
abroad and stay there the laws and the
mentality of act what does XX mean is
that like a sling XX need to be changed
before the West can be saved silly
sausage she wants the man to stop her
from her own female desire to run off a
man to save her from her own selfish
choices he has to be responsible to stop
her from her own nature to go eat the
poison apple Lawrence Bullock great
panel Lively debate good job Pro respect
um okay guys so I'm going to close out
the show so any final thoughts any
social media you want to plug do that
now start here and then go around
okay yeah I'll just go into that so OG
zero l-u-w-a underscore OMG
yeah it's your boy my name is China my
name's voice uh make sure you get me on
Instagram Tick Tock and make sure you
subscribe to my channel my name is China
shout out to Doug MPA my guy is really
showing love and yeah man just I just
want to thank Paul because I think I
don't know how many times I've been like
well can I call myself a regular now can
I do that yeah okay cool I think it's
like the seventh time I've been on here
um and since I've been on I've been
doing other podcasts as well I just want
to thank perfect opportunity because
they'll be loving China in these streets
man they're recognizing this [ __ ] you
know what I mean we got a blessing too
man yeah all right cool oh thank you
yeah I'd like to thank Paul as well for
having this platform it's a really cool
platform so yeah you can find me outside
your psychology both tiktok and
Instagram and I do like lots of like
therapy and relationship advice and all
that stuff so you can find that at some
of the psychology
oh yeah um
thank you for having me on the Pod um my
name is meiwa mashallah my friends call
me King I'm a videographer and yeah you
can find me on Instagram at Kingo
mashallah which is
k-i-n-g-o-m-a-t-s-o-l-a
and I also want to get into the podcast
thing as well um I have a podcast
um coming up called The Royal African
Mill yeah so yeah you can hit me up on
that as well I'm coming on that yeah 100
yeah
um yeah big up Pearl this podcast is
great I love being on here
um if you want to find me on Instagram
beard gang members uh for you man that's
trying to get more masculine more Alpha
you want to attract the women who need
the full beard you know what I'm saying
so yeah you're making magic happen be a
gang members hit me up
okay guys um thank you all for coming
this was a fun panel tonight guys like
the video on your way out a like is the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out these videos so make sure
you like the video subscribe to the
channel and our two clips channel is the
first being just pearly clips and the
second being Pearl daily
um also guys make sure you join our
memberships the first you get to be a
part of the live chat the second you get
to be a part of our discords and our
behind the scenes Vlogs third you
connect with us on social media and
fourth you get a one-on-one call with me
once a month thank you for six whatever
yeah 6.75 I think right now let me let
me let me update it 6.75 almost 676
000 subscribers that's mad like 200k
this month just this month so it's mad
because I started the show um I think
end of in March or February last year so
it's really only been seven eight months
you guys have been crazy
um also guys go follow my Instagram just
pearly things one um I got my old one
taken away so make sure you go follow
that one and go follow my new tick tock
just probably thinks dot five and just
probably things six
um that's my backup one in case they
take away the fifth one thank you guys
for watching